the Biden Administration has held secret
meetings over US troops being deployed
into Gaza to occupy the Gaza Strip and
we also have reporting now this I think
we all knew Special Forces US Special
Forces are on the ground in Israel with
speculation that they're actively
working in Gaza the Special Forces are
there reportedly to help identify
hostages us hostages but considering
that they are engaged in a ground
operation in Gaza the speculation is
that they uh uh that US forces are in
Gaza too so uh hey maybe it it all just
goes Belly Up and this becomes another
big mess where the United States ends up
losing another War cuz uh you know we
backed Ukraine and they lost and
Afghanistan and Iraq are disasters and
oh boy we can go back in time but here
we are we got more news this one's
interesting new polls are coming out out
and they're all starting to include RFK
Jr so now it's a three-way race with
Biden Trump and RFK Jr and guess what
guess who loses in almost every one of
these polls well Kennedy obviously no
disrespect and Joe Biden now there was
one poll that shows that uh kipc shows
that Trump loses if Kennedy runs but all
the other polls they're showing that if
Kennedy is on the ballot Donald Trump
beats Joe Biden and the scary thing is
it's like 35 to 37 so people are not
going to be too happy about those
numbers we'll get into that before we
get started my friends head over to cast
brew.com to buy cast brew coffee it's
the best cup of coffee you'll ever have
pick up our Halloween and Thanksgiving I
guess limited edition rise with Roberto
Jr we're going to have that up until we
sell out of these and then there is
going to be no more ever again but we do
have a couple thousand so I think they
might be up for a month or two months
but this is the uh rise with Roberto Jr
medium roast of course everyone's
favorite is rise with Roberto Jr like
breakfast blend when you support cbw do
uh Cas brew.com and buy coffee here
you're supporting the work we do here as
well as the coffee shop plan that we got
we're going to create physical spaces
for y'all to hang out meet up with each
other and help build culture but also
don't forget to go to
timcast.net 55 per month level to submit
questions and this is a screening
process we have to do because you know
they're bad apples that want to kind of
ruin the fun for everybody but also
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a lot more is J.R
majusi hey Tim thanks for having me man
who are you what do you do so I'm a uh
Republican candidate for the Ninth
District of Ohio for Congress and uh I
was the 2022 nominee and unfortunately
because of some democratic smears I
ended up losing my election but um you
I'm back into the race this cycle you're
also a big nuclear energy guy yeah
former nuclear energy guy U specialized
in spent nuclear fuel so wow all right
we'll definitely talk about that Hannah
CLA is here hey I'm Hannah Clair brimo
I'm a writer for
timcast.net
debut debut I'm back I don't know return
return what's up hello everyone I'm back
from Miami I had an incredible relaxing
rejuvenating Spirit Quest it was amazing
and I want to give a shout out to some
people that I met along the way Adam s
from the value tainment Network thanks
for having me on Adam on uh on sast that
was a good time also Lauren de lagona
pixie Amy Dangerfield from the upand
cominging pink pill podcast you're going
to want to check it out on YouTube
Destiny had me on his show lyen destiny
Chef the man thanks for making dinner
for us and of course Luc rowski who
hosted me with we are change and Clint
Russell we did some shows if you haven't
seen him yet go to rumble and check out
Luc rowski we are changed it was so much
fun Luke thank you good to be back Tim
thanks man we got surge to my right yes
I'm here glad to have you back again and
uh ready to start the show when you are
Tim here we go man here's the story from
the Daily Mail Biden Administration
holds secret talks on stationing
American troops in Gaza after Hamas is
defeated but us officials fear deepening
political Peril after Israel shelled a
refugee camp oh boy there's so much here
uh so it's not a refugee camp here we go
again and uh but we'll get into this
because there are civilian deaths it's
just man is this is just lies lies lies
but here's here's the worrying part of
the story first Bloomberg I love their
warmongering headline us and Israel
weigh peacekeepers for the Gaza Strip
what does that mean let's just say it
like it is Bloomberg the US wants US
soldiers in Gaza now here's what's
important to understand the way they're
framing it is after Hamas after well
Times of Israel citing the New York
Times says that us special forces are
already deployed into Israel on the
ground to assist with recovering
hostages but come on what does that mean
this means special forces are going to
be working on I mean I I I don't see any
other argument that could be made you I
suppose you could argue the US Special
Forces are just in a in a room somewhere
in Tel Aviv you know giving Intel and
giving advice I don't think we use
special forces for that but maybe the
most likely thing is they are engaged in
recovery which we on this show warned
about several a month ago that or not
not even a month a few weeks ago that if
us uh uh Citi are taken captive are
kidnapped then the US typically sends
boots on the ground to bring them back
and so now that we're seeing this let me
put it all together for you what seems
more likely US Special Forces are
already in Gaza engaged in operations
which will result in the removal of
Hamas by which then the US wants to send
more US troops into
Gaza well how how are you guys doing I'm
thinking about Vietnam cuz I saw that
word Peacekeeper and I remember they
started off the Vietnam uh surge of
troops by calling them advisers so there
was wasn't really a war wasn't even
really considered a military expedition
in the 50s I think it was the late 50s
when they started sending their advisers
over there and uh you know it just
scaled from there so it kind of tastes
like
that what do you think I like oh and I
also think that if there's one if they
get all the hostages out but then
there's one left they'll use that as a
reason to send 10,000 guys in they'll
just they just want to conquer the place
they'll just say oh there's still 10
Americans whose identities are being
remained secret private because of the
risk of their family and uh got to send
in the troops I mean that's it I mean
the US is is here here's my fear I hope
none of this happens but it seems like
they're doing these things so that they
slowly introduce you into the idea that
there will be troops in Gaza cuz uh does
anybody remember the exact date when the
US announced that they were declaring
war on Syria and sending troops into
Syria yeah most people don't and I was
surprised at one point I remember
hearing about US troops in Syria I was
like wait what when did we go into Syria
like we're we're in Syria at first it
was like there are no troops in Syria
and then like oh we actually have bases
there now yeah they started as we're
just sending them to help with something
it's sort of almost a humanitarian
effort that we sent our military to take
care of and then it just escalates to
being like well we need to always have a
presence there because without without
us what would they do I mean this is the
thing that bothers me the most about uh
the way the American government leans on
its military which is to say we can send
troops to all kinds of places across the
world but we do not send them to the
Border which protects our own citizens
right we got to stop being everything to
everybody or stop trying to be
everything to everybody we can be
everything to everybody here in the US
exactly that's right that's let's let's
do that and you know that's why I'm
saying I see all these like uh there's
like genz videos on Tik Tok where
they're like we should have free
education and free healthare and we're
spending money or the funny thing is you
get this young woman and she's a
communist and she's like Society like
the the the current generation is
suffering the economy is terrible we're
living paycheck to paycheck when we
could be having if you free healthcare
and free college and I'm like here we go
and then she goes but instead we're
spending it all in the military
industrial complex and I'm like deal all
right I'll take it if we stop funding
blowing up kids in foreign countries and
then we apply whatever money is is left
from that into like giving Medical Care
to people like deal left you can have
that if we if we all agree to stop doing
this maybe that's their game though the
establishment is like let's let's let's
stress the American people by blowing up
kids as many kids as possible around the
world till they beg us we will give you
authoritarian control if you stop
blowing actually a technocratic tactic
they want to give us War weariness until
we'll say please give us anything but
War including putting people into pods
and medicating them making them meet the
bugs I think they'll just have a taste
for it at that point like but war is so
fun we make so much money off of it
we'll continue on yeah it's back to the
FDR right the FDR Theory right where he
goated us into World War II by um
meddling with Japan because he needed it
to satisfy his promises of the of the
New Deal what was he doing with Japan
well they he put tariffs and and meddled
with you know their trade on steel and
it there there was a lot too it was uh
the US is supplying weapons and
resources to enemies of Japan and to the
Allied Forces into China yeah yeah and
so I mean right over a long enough
period of time if like let's say Hannah
Clair and Ian are throwing snowballs at
each other and then I'm I'm making
snowballs and handing them to Ian Hannah
Clair is going to be like dude you're
both fighting me yeah I'll be really mad
about it I will be honest all I do is
make snowballs yeah he's just a guy I
know just a guy I know yeah right and
meanwhile like last night there there
was a a viral clip of a veteran that was
crying uh sitting in his car talking
about the fact that you know yeah I mean
we have we have veterans here that you
know there's an increasing rise on
veteran suicides and their their mental
health and the care that they receive
from the VA it's just terrible and I I
saw that video and I'm like how do we
help this guy yeah right how do we help
him and then I'm just like the problem
is how do you help all of them right you
know we we the the I I I'll tell you I
despise the political Elites the
political class so much and uh a lot of
these very wealthy political uh Dynasty
families and I'm not just talking about
like the clintons or whatever oh there's
way more than that people need to
understand they're like we we know the
kennedies we know the bushes we know the
clintons but there are bureaucrat
families there are midlevel manager type
families that live in these wealthy
areas and their families are all getting
in government and they hate you they use
your children as Canon fodder and then
what do you get your sons and daughters
coming back to this country and they're
told to go f themselves left to cry in
their cars because they can't get any
medical care and then they take more of
your money and your labor and they go
blow up kids with it yeah I mean I've
never seen a president campaign on I
will fix the VA the VA VA historically
has all kinds of administrative problems
but it's just sort of like oh I love the
troops see you guys when I see you even
though we offer this this healthc care
system that is always fundamentally
broken right I've never heard of a
veteran who doesn't eventually have an
issue along the way and I'm not saying
that there aren't VA doctors VA systems
that are trying their best it's just
incredibly difficult I don't understand
why we don't hear more about uh fixing
our own domestic support systems rather
than constantly saying well we we we've
got to have this presence on the
geopolitical stage like why I'd rather
be present in our own Nation I get when
Ben Shapiro comes out and he says here
is my argument for war like not for war
but like why war is happening we didn't
he's like he's like Israel didn't start
it I I don't know if he says we but uh
Israel didn't start it Hamas starts it
this current round I know there's
generational conflict here but I get it
Ben Shapiro says Israel is Justified in
doing these things for these reasons and
I'm like oh that's really interesting
why is the US involved in this right why
why why who in this country I mean benir
obviously thinks the US needs to be
involved to prevent destabilization of
the region eventually World War I I I
get his arguments I would argue the
inverse I don't know which one is more
likely to happen but the US sending
troops into Gaza sounds like you're
going to get I don't know who the rebels
in Yemen and Iranian backed militias
directly attacking isra Israeli like
territory I mean the US going in maybe
there the the hope is that it will be
such a massive shock to the rest of
these these countries it will stop them
from doing anything if the US is in
Israel they're going to be like we can't
go to war with the US yeah I get that
that feeling of like wow if they finally
take over then it's going to be done we
don't have to worry about it anymore
that's just not the way it works man
blowback is generational you kill all
those people you'll see their families
and their friends for for tens of
hundreds like what is he was going to do
occupy Gaza for 20 years I mean it's I
joked almost when I said make it the
51st state now I'm seeing things like
they want to colonize they want walking
back completely know it's funny because
the the and the way you phrase making
Gaza the 5st State everyone's just like
the process there is impossible and then
it was funny because I was like what Ian
are we going to send troops into Gaza
and Spark World War II and now Biden's
like we should send troops in Gaza and
I'm like soly got a call from the Biden
Administration being like more ideas
more ideas not to mention the acute
impact right you're you're stretching
America's military thin and as we're
seeing right now there's probably
sleeper cells all over the country and
how are we going to defend ourselves we
can't I mean it's you know the way I say
it is like you know you can't go to your
neighbors house and and uh chastise them
for a dirty kitchen when your kitchen's
terribly distraught right and it's not
about just the cleanliness it's about
being able to feed and clothe and
everything else that comes along with
having a kitchen I mean it's a decent
analogy but at the end of the day you
know we're not even keeping our own
house clean youever medling everywhere
else you ever see those stories about
the people on Facebook who have to
monitor like political content and like
rural violations there's a couple
different versions of the story one is
like people see horrifying murder and
stuff and they're traumatized and they
quit but there was another story where
it's like a couple of them where these
people are working in politics in the
like we got to get rid of fake news and
we got to get rid of you know like rule
breaks people breaking the rules and
they started turning rightwing yeah
because they started seeing these memes
and then they kept seeing them over and
over and over again as they're supposed
to be policing and banning these stories
they end up seeing a whole bunch of
stories and then eventually they're like
Trump's right yeah and so I'm just
hoping that you know like Hezbollah and
Hamas they send in these in Iran they
send these sleeper cells into the United
States 20 years ago and then they're
like they show up and cross the border
and they're like when our time comes the
infidels will pay and now it's like 20
years later and they're morbidly obese
and on Tik Tok and they're going to
Pride parades and stuff watching Marvel
movies yeah watching Marvel mov I'm
hoping the indoctrination went the other
direction with them and they've just
been like what were we complaining about
this is great I wouldn't be surprised if
that does happen sometimes and the segue
on that um you know I remember seeing
that story and one of the things that I
took away was that the Facebook uh
people that were monitoring these nasty
memes or whatever they were seeing all
this traumatizing footage they're
getting better Medical Care and mental
health care than our troops right so
you're a veteran of the Air Force like
what's the system what's the status of
the VA what's the problem and what I
guess if you think Solutions I don't
know personally you know um I've never
sought VA benefits after the after the
service I probably could for for certain
things but I just never did I just
always felt like you know there's guys
and and women that were worse off than
me so but I do have some friends that
work for the veterans administration and
I can tell you that you know they they
communicated to me and from veteran
friends there was a pretty distinct
difference when Trump was in office
because he broke the bureaucracy he he
actually um created a mechanism in which
the VA doctors could be held accountable
and before it was kind of like the
fouchy thing you know he can do whatever
he want he's he's not an elected
official so on and so forth and you know
Trump came in and changed that Paradigm
and um a lot of veterans were getting
better service but you know with Biden
now I mean I'm mean he he reverted
everything within days of being in
office do we do we need a private
company that to rival the VA and do it
better I mean I wouldn't argue that you
know I think veterans are pretty simple
we you know we don't want much we just
want Healthcare we want we want the
benefits that we signed up for right and
I don't have all that trauma I can't you
know no ptsc I don't have any of that
but you I have friends that do and um
it's come to the point where they're
they're seeking Care on their own um you
know they're they're doing different
things maybe it's meditation or you know
I don't think that's bad right have
alternative ways to intervene I just
think the issue is when you know you're
being told we don't know when we can see
you we have crazy delays or programs
where if you come you know you have to
be shipped to a different VA to have
some sort of treatment and then you
don't have the support in that area I
mean it's it's a link it's not that any
medical system in the US is so great but
in this case one of the things that
especially young men in this in in
America are told is if you sign up and
serve you will have this resource for a
long time your family will have this
resource and we know the VA is okay with
offering veterans children's hormones
but they can't always get counselors in
place for veterans who need it for PTSD
treatment I mean the priorities of the
of the VA seem very strange to me and
again I want to believe in good faith
that there are people who are really
trying to do as much as they can and
that the bureaucracy is is holding them
back but it's hard to say we need more
in my opinion more experimental
treatment in the VA like MDMA therapy
and things because the wars that we're
experiencing are experimental Wars with
experimental technology like bombs are a
new technology they kill everything in
the vicinity they don't discriminate to
see that would I mean the brain is not I
don't think the brains are built for
that yet well no I agree right I I love
that scene in the movie Snatch you guys
ever watched that movie with Jason
Statham and who else is in there there's
a bunch of guys it's a guy Richie movie
and in the beginning you got that scene
where Turkish is talking to his buddy
and his buddy's like you shouldn't drink
milk it's out of sync with Evolution and
then he explains that like humans evolve
eating like he's explaining the paleo
diet basically but to to to shift that
to your point Ian humans did not develop
over thousands of years seeing like
dozens of people get limbs blown off all
an instant no I get it War existed and
there was brutal stuff and people being
hit and people dying and there's Gore
and stuff but yeah bombs like regular
old bomb like grenades are out of sync
with Evolution humans witnessing that
stuff is well beyond what humans you
know grew to ever experience I felt I
was walking through New York City one
day and I just felt a demolition uh five
six blocks away the entire Earth Shook
and I still feel it in my gut when I
think about it yeah I had a buddy that
to your point too you know when you come
out of the military you're used to a a
you know a community of of structure and
camaraderie and a lot of these veterans
just want support they just want to have
an outlet that isn't their family so
they're not placing this emotional
burden on them and you know to to some
of these uh um you know holistic
treatment types I have a friend Nick
Nick mson um who's you know double
Purple Heart recipient Burnt Over like
90% of his body I just posted a thing
about him on Twitter today absolute hero
and this guy you know struggled with the
VA for years was terrified to come out
of his home he had so much Trauma from a
PTSD standpoint but the guy found his
way and you know he he's he's doing
great today but you know just the seeing
the things that he had to go through
it's just it's it's horrific if if if
the American public understood some of
the things these veterans are going
through and and in exchange for what
they're asking for I mean this is this
is an easy easy decision I wonder if we
should have maybe like what's a good age
15 sophomore year of high school make
make uh these teens actually watch war
footage real war footage actually ex
watch and see what it's like and then
when it comes time to vote again when
they're older they're going to be like
no no please no yeah let I'm sorry man
the idea that we we got to shelter our
kids from the harsh realities of War
means they grow up completely oblivious
to it and then vote for it cuz they have
no idea but imagine if you if if if
there was a young kid who actually
witnessed something you know we we like
the challenge is you don't want to you
don't want to break you want to make and
you never know if you're going to make
or break someone with something but
there's too many people who don't
understand what they're voting for when
they vote for war when they celebrate
war and they're volunteering you all to
go and do it not them they're going to
vote for war they're not going to go
fight it right they want our men and
women in uniform to go to go do these
things and then when they come back it's
like I forgot about it well I just read
that in uh Ukraine they were the draft
age has been raised again I think and
the average uh Ukrainian male fighter is
44 43 years old years old average yeah
they're they're they're pulling they're
pulling people off trains apparently
there'll be like a 50 something year old
guy in a train and they'll walk in and
grab him be like nope front line and
they just send him right to the front
line hand him a gun say good luck so I'm
with you on exposing people to the
horror ahead of time but then I also
still want people to volunteer for the
military because we need domestic
defense and I think I'm not sure what
you think maybe the balance is J yeah
but
look do you so I I I used to work at
this office and their hiring practice
was to put up fake ads for what the job
is this is what all these nonprofits do
they call it campaign work they say work
on campaigns to save the forests or
whatever and then what happens is when
when you come in for the interview they
say oh you know you'll be filling out
forms and talking to people about what
you believe and they go okay then you
bring you for another meeting and then
they finally land on you're going to be
asking people for
strangers in the street and they're like
the reason we do this is because if we
tell people what the job is they won't
show up and I'm like so you think it
makes more sense for me to interview 50
people of which 49 leave instead of just
waiting for the one guy to show up who
wants to do the job and so that that's
my view with you know with with the
military in this regard obviously you
don't want to shock young people in
horrifying ways but they do need to be
aware of what it really means to be you
know uh uh to be in the armed forces to
be a to be combat infantry and what it
means to vote for it and then perhaps
the people who volunteer are the people
who truly understand what they're
signing up for yeah I mean I feel this
would be the most helpful in high
schools in blue areas right I mean in my
personal experience you know I grew up
in Connecticut Blue State my brother
enlisted in high school to be in the
Marine Corps and his high school fought
him tooth and nail the entire way he was
18 all a senior year so he could he
could be enlisted but they were like no
don't you want to go to College don't
you want to do this thing you have to be
over here you have to do this thing they
have no military family members
themselves maybe they're grandfathers
but they there's no actual connection to
it and so there is a a idea that that's
for someone else to do that is some
that's not for me that's not my
experience and again like this is an
issue I feel very strongly about but in
addition to the combat in addition to
the the physical labor that goes being
into the military in addition to the
impact it has on the family if you
choose to get married and get shipped
around the US I mean it's a really
serious sacrifice the other part is that
we don't transition people out of the
military very effectively so we don't
offer career Counseling in a way that
people can really say this is what I did
in the military this is what it looks
like in the civilian world it's a system
that we both depend on and are willing
to send other people to go fight but
when people are here domestically we
don't think about them I wonder if a lot
of the problems of wokeness and
communism and you know far-left ideology
could just be solved by exposing young
people to the realities of life I you
know when I see these videos and they're
like we should have free free education
free healthcare I'm like this person's
never had a job when they're like you
know you know there's more empty houses
than homeless people we could put we
could house and feed every homeless
person I'm like this person's never
worked with the homeless and they've
never owned a house yeah so how you know
let's expose young people to the
realities of life and then have them be
like oh I was wrong yeah yeah and I
think there are young people who grew up
and you know the reality is it's
typically children teenagers that are
growing up in more improver more
bluecollar areas who have to see what
their parents par are going through
they're living in a circumstance where
they are exposed earlier it's the and
this is not to be mean to them but it's
it's the upper middle class to wealthy
uh teenagers in America who are in super
Progressive schools especially super
Progressive private schools who then go
on to say I know better than everyone
else on the face of the Earth because I
know that who's oppressed and I know
what the world colonizer means that I
support that group I mean it's
ridiculous it's very out of touch but
it's not true universally it's just it's
true in places with influence I'm a
living example of that you know I grew
up in a blueco collar family I grew up
in uh you know Toledo Ohio in the one of
the worst the the worst neighborhood in
my district and you know my dad worked
at uh Toledo Jeep built cars for a
living and um you know I didn't have a
choice when I got out of the out of out
of high school and to your point you
know if I would have known more about
college I would have started college
earlier and nobody was there to teach me
I had you know I'm the first grandkid to
ever graduate from college oh I hate
college so college is this scame it is
I'm with Randy Marsh on this one I just
watched South Park Panda verse we
watched it earlier today I love it when
they're like college is a scam and they
fire they try to fire a catapult into it
oh it was that I recommend South Park
the panda verse it's really good it's
not just about wokeness it's about uh
the failures of the economy and they
roast the they roast Communists so so
well it's anyway it's the color
Revolution man but you know back to what
I was saying with with being blue collar
right um you know not having a choice
when I got out of the uh you know out of
high school what path was I going to
take you I had a very strict
really strict father and Military just
became clear as my only choice and
absolutely love the country I've always
been patriotic and you know it seemed
like this was my path at least four
years I could start off somewhere and um
you know growing up watching my dad work
12 16 hour shifts every day coming home
couldn't coach the baseball team you
know things like that you know it it it
really had an impact on me so you know
after the military um you know my dad
and I couldn't sit in the same room and
not agree that these walls are gray you
know but after the service coming home I
had a proud dad you know we be became
really good friends and you know the
military you know changed my life but to
your point Tim if I would have known
about certain things at an earlier age I
would have made different life decisions
but yep I think college has become a lot
more of a scam since the internet
because before it was a good place to go
congregate with Geniuses and learn about
data but now it's so uh obsolete in my
opin maybe for certain things it's worth
going when it became a money machine
right not just you know uh the argument
I often would hear from people back in
the day about college is it's where you
go to congregate with other like-minded
individuals and work on ideas and I'm
like but I've been doing that my whole
life yeah and then you look at without
naming any of these individuals there
are certain uh uh people would call them
prodigies you know young people who were
in C in certain Fields succeeding at
early ages but the reality was these
people would go on they were online when
they were like 12 or 13 and they were in
physics forums talking with physicists
and then people were like wait a minute
this kid 15 the person who was helping
us theorize these things is a kid and
they're like oh he's a prodigy it's like
no he was justos in this space and
exposed to it and contributed the guy
who built and developed uh minds.com the
company that I co-founded with Bill
opman Mark Harding he's the C uh CTO and
uh he was 17 when he started building it
but he just learned it all online you
just look copy paste read the data this
means that this means that and he just I
think universities made sense when they
were about getting people in places to
discuss ideas Advanced you know academic
knowledge that that was great but right
now college is actually just an
extension of high school right I mean
it's unusual it's it's the American
University system where you're having
assignments to turn in every week or
stuff like that like that was not how
these institutions were founded you're
supposed to come up with like a thesis
that you work on for four years and
that's all you do and now we have
general education classes and this that
and the other and it's ultimately all to
make money with especially uh government
backed student loans that they still
issue even though we know it's setting
up millions of students every year for
complete Financial ruin and so
ultimately it's marketing this idea that
you will get a better job you'll have
something else because of this the
degree but the degree doesn't actually
make you better a better thinker it just
tells you that you can comply with the
rules set out for you which I don't
personally think is a value that I would
want to instill in children you know at
past a certain age you want young
children to learn obedience and
discipline but when you're reach
maturity you should be expanding your
intellectual curiosity and pursuing your
interest and that's not what happens to
the universities anymore so uh the South
Park Pander verse episode that
everyone's been talking about it's
marketed as the characters are replaced
by diverse women so Cartman is a black
woman now but there's there's an a story
and a b story and the B story is that no
one knows how to do anything and so uh
Randy Marsh stand's dad the stove breaks
and he's like I'm going to show you kids
how to fix the stove the stove door so
he calls the handyman and then the
handyman's like well I'm going to have
to come back later you're you know the
the the screws are stripped and he's
like wait I'll pay you more money to
stay and fix it now and he goes ah
someone already paid me more money to go
fix theirs now so what happens is all
the all the handymen end up becoming
billionaires and then when none of the
regular people can get their light bulbs
fixed or their power outlets fixed or
anything fixed they start blaming the
billionaires because the handy men are
all billionaires and then they start
holding up we are the 99% signs they're
saying capitalism has failed they're
like all these billionaires are
withholding their access to this work
and we can't get anything fixed now it's
their fault capitalism's failed and I'm
just like it's really really funny
because it exemplifies so much of what
the left complains about especially
young people they're just like if they
can't have it right away it's the rich
person's fault yeah it also highlights
the value of artisanry and like before
you were lucky to find someone that knew
how to forge a steel sword you had to
spend time with that person now we're in
a we're in a point in history where it's
all available if you want to become a
plumber you can figure it out but if all
this power goes out you're not going to
you're going to have to find a plumber
to learn or just trial and error book
maybe books if you have access to them
if you're lucky and maybe you had one
and there's still a library standing
well so that that was a funny part of
the show is that they basically spoiler
alerts I guess they're just like the
real the real problem was College
Randy's like if I didn't spend eight
years getting a PhD in geology I'd know
how to actually fix things and do work
and then I'd be rich and so they go and
start protesting the colleges it's good
it's really good well like what do you
want out of life right if you want to
make a certain amount of money so you
can have a career you like and then also
pursue your interest and you know start
new businesses or travel or whatever
else going to college doesn't actually
make sense you're going into massive
amount of debts you don't have the
guarantee of job you should look at
trades you should look at all kinds of
other things where it takes less initial
investment you're able to if you have to
take it alone pay it off much faster and
then also you have the option to work in
a variety of settings this is the thing
about you know and I I I got my
bachelor's in English I feel comfortable
saying this who knows what I was going
to do with that what does that even mean
like what's a bachelor's in English so
the bachelor's degree is just the like
four-year degree for English it's
English literature so I can tell you a
lot about poetry I can write some
interesting essays my second one I have
two degrees second one was in
communication studies and so you took
basic classes in communication Theory
some like Public Relation stuff it
worked out it's fine if we open a poetry
store do you think it would do I'm slam
well that was the thing when I reached
the end of my four degree they were like
would you like to work for Teach for
America I was like I don't want
Communicator though I mean absolutely I
already knew how to talk beforehand
right I could spent four years reading
the news doing something else I'm
grateful for college you know I had a
good experience because I like I liked
being in class I liked learning do I
think it's worth the investment no see I
reject this right this is one of the
arguments I've heard a lot from people
when they're like I think college was
good for me and I'm like you don't know
if it was good for you because you don't
know what you would done if you didn't
do it and to be honest the things that I
tell people about college is that I was
really grateful to go to a different
environment I went college in Texas it's
you know more Bible Bell I was around
people very different people socially
and that was interesting that was that
was a a Prof had a profoundly uh
positive impact on my life but it's not
to say that college is the reason I am
where I am to today it just I'd argue it
holds you back and this is this is what
a lot I would say to a lot of people I
knew in their you know mid 20s or
whatever they're like I went to college
and I'm doing all right and I'm like
look man I'm not trying to be a dick to
you but you're a shift supervisor at a
Starbucks making $15 an hour and you're
25 okay there are people who have
started their own businesses by the time
they were 22 I know people who became
managers of fast food restaurants by the
time they were 23 and they're making you
know 40,000 a year so I'm not trying to
be you know it's like you don't want to
be a dick to someone who's like I think
I'm doing all right cuz you want to
cheer them on but it's like look man we
can't keep encouraging people to stunt
their lives by going to college instead
of learning how to actually work in ways
that can benefit their fellow man sure
especially it's not the only option and
that's the thing that I think American
high schools get wrong which is that
they they use the statistics of how many
people matriculate to college to say
that we are a really good high school
but that's a bad that's a bad statistic
you might as well say our graduating
class is entering multi-million dollars
worth of debt do you think we are a good
high school that would be a more
accurate way of representing what they
think students can accomplish it's
making me think of a question for ugr
about what knowing that like the trade
how valuable trades are and the ability
to build you you were project management
for energy companies or at least one in
particular what company First Energy for
First Energy you developed you know
you're saying a campus at one point or
you You' designed what made you or what
made you decide to Pivot away from that
into politics well it kind of goes back
to you know where I started so I started
in the Union at the power plants and um
the barrier to management for me was a
degree it was it was a prerequisite in
in the power industry so ended up
finishing my Master's Degree I you know
I was a really hard worker and I caught
the attention of the site vice president
when Davis Bessie nuclear power plant in
Ohio had the reactor head incident and
um you know I I just was a hard work and
and a lot of it comes to what from what
Tim saying right you you apply your hard
work ethic but then you supplement that
with the knowledge that you gain you
know from college I went to college late
in life I I didn't go right after high
school you that was the service so you
know the pivot for me though to politics
was um coid I was traveling the country
200 some days a year I was working at
different nuclear reactors across the
country and uh Co had me working out of
a home office and I became politically
active because of Donald Trump uh my dad
was a lifelong Democrat and he was a
huge Donald Trump fan and he talked me
into you know paying more attention to
Trump and I did and um the the long
story short is in 2020 um a veterans
group and I that I support um I painted
the Trump 2020 logo on my big big yard
and on Lake Erie and it went viral I was
on Fox and Friends and then I got a call
from president Trump and W it it just it
just grew from there and um I ended up
developing a a decent Twitter following
for a guy from Northwest Ohio and uh
when I watched what happened during the
2020 election and I watched what was
going on in my district you know 40-year
Democratic incumbent doing nothing for
us I decided that I was going to use the
political Capital that I gained and just
shake some trees it was a democratic
plus 12 District I had no chance in hell
to win but luckily right you know right
before the right after the before the
primary election they redistricted the
district flipped to a r republican plus
2.9 and here I am the candidate I beat
two elected officials State elected
officials absolutely demolished them and
I was on my way to run in the general
election so the pivot for me was just
becoming aware of what was going on in
American politics and knowing that I
grew up in poverty I grew up in a
struggle and what I was seeing happening
um by these oligarchs and these you know
wealthy folks it just it didn't make
sense that let's let's pull up this uh
the story we have this poll from
Quinnipiac this one's got people all hot
and bothered 2024 presidential race
stays static in the face of major events
quc University National poll finds RFK
Jr receives 22% as independent candidate
in three-way race now the interesting
thing here is that with the independent
candidate they say that Joe Biden wins
they say uh uh well let me just pull up
the actual Quinnipiac here from 538 they
say actually it looks like if they
include Cornell West but Joe Biden gets
39% Trump gets 36 and Kennedy gets 22
now a lot of people are responding
especially Trump supporters being like
what's 22% who that are you polling now
Quin Beck also has this poll including
Corell West I love it if Cornell West
runs apparently Trump still loses okay
hold on a minute I I'm I'm like it's
really funny when they put both of these
matches out at the same time okay so
it's Biden Trump Kennedy on the ticket
Kennedy gets 22% but if you add Cornell
West someone pulls one point away from
Donald Trump are they implying Cornell
West will take 1% of Trump's voters
Cornell West he's he's he's super far
left right I mean I just that's
ridiculous he's he's courting the same
demographic As Trump 100% sure I that's
just it's a ridiculous idea that Trump
would lose because of West and Kennedy
and when you look at all the other polls
take a look at this one Redfield Wilton
strategies Kennedy 10% Trump wins 40 to
38 they have another poll showing it's
35 to 33 with Kennedy at 10% probably
because they might have Cornell West in
there you have this one from mclin Biden
35 Trump 38 Kennedy 12 West to mcclaflin
also has Trump winning all the other
polls at least Abacus has a tie so
there's one poll showing Trump losing I
guess technically a quit has 2 and then
ABAC showing a tie and the other polls
we've got uh one two I believe three
four uh four other polls showing Trump
wins with Kennedy on the uh on the
ballot I I don't know for sure but I'm
I'm definitely leaning towards I do not
see Trump voters leaving I'm talking
about not I'm talking about Maga I'm
talking about moderate independent types
I don't see them being like I'll vote
for Kennedy instead of trump some maybe
but it's mostly going to be Democrats
who think Biden can't win and that Biden
is horrible he's corrupt he's a
warmonger and they're going to vote for
for for Kennedy I agree I think I think
Biden's doing all the work for him you
know all the work for these other
candidates right now in my district in
Ohio it's it's highly independent and
you know I I see a huge swing for um
voters driving towards Trump just
because of what he's standing for and
and the fact that he's getting attacked
so terribly they're they're seeing the
reality of politics right now I heard a
Biden speech from I guess four years ago
and man he sounded clear like a normal
guy and now when you listen to him it is
freakish he is just tired it's
exponential you know it's like the the
decline accelerates the older you get so
it's a curve straight straight down I'm
so concerned I'm torn because I'd like
to meet him and help his help his brain
a little bit cuz he is our commander you
can't help his brain e just listen to
him like let him kind of wake himself up
a little bit well and it's degenerative
right I mean that's the sad thing about
dementia illnesses right like any kind
of elderly atrophying it it's not
reversible it's not coming back you
can't I've seen THC consume amalo plaque
which is the cause of Alzheimer's in in
a microscope I'd have to continue to
look for more data to back that up but I
think believe I've seen that also I hear
psilocybin helps people an older age
there might be in the future but right
now we have very little if any way at
all to slow or stop these Progressive
degenerative diseases and I think that's
stem cells right to the brain yeah I
mean maybe there's something and maybe
if we're testing them you know
experimental treatments you know giving
us an option in the VA maybe you know
Biden can get have a chance to try this
out but realistically in the next year
he is not going to suddenly imp improve
considering we've seen a consistent
decline in the last three years so if he
walked into a chamber and it would
closed like and he came out and he
looked like 38 would you vote for him no
if he was healthy like a 30y he's a
Democrat I mean I still evil he can look
he's young evil he he would look 38 and
I still need him to close the border
which he won't do he wasn't get all that
Biden money back though from the the Gap
you yeah what's this what's the story
now they they $40,000 in in laundered
payments oh what's that yeah yeah
there's like U so there was the $200,000
payment from his brother now apparently
there's a report about $440,000 paid
directly to Joe Biden which appears to
be laundered from China M man I'm glad
you brought up the Border it's just I I
probably you guys about it a lot I hope
hopefully it gets talked about a lot and
are they building it up right now
because it's like yo if we're really
going to about to spark a war in the
Middle East or like jump into the fire
over there we better have closed borders
yeah I mean at this point that would
sense yes if if if you were in a
dangerous neighborhood I've said this
100 times on the show but if you were in
a dangerous neighborhood you would lock
your own front door and instead we're
like no it's fine let's open all of the
windows let's just pretend like
everything is cool but it's not just
that if you're going to throw a flaming
bag of feces at your neighbor's house
you're going to also lock your doors
because your neighbor is going to get
mad at you now I'm that I guess I could
technically say the US is basically
doing this because we shouldn't be
involved in this stuff anyway but the US
getting involved in all of these
conflicts and leaving the back door
open yeah and the front door with Canada
like I know there are allies but that
doesn't mean Canadian or that doesn't
mean like Chinese tanks can't just roll
through central Canada into like there's
no barrier dude no there was a there was
a story about a bunch of like 20y olds
and they just drove down the border and
then just turned into the United States
mhm I think they got in trouble the
Pacific Northwest yeah cuz there's no
barriers there no you know there's just
like it's like the trees are cut and
they have drones Patrol sometimes you go
to the southern border and it's like
some some areas you know there's nothing
but there's a lot of baller fencing and
then there's patrols that go up and down
and you've got the militias down there
yeah didn't we have the Chinese military
was caught practicing some drill or
performing military drills in Canada
last year if I'm not mistaken I don't
think they were caught I think that was
like a joint effort between Canada and
China man yeah it seems like the Chinese
don't want any military conflict with
the US they had Gavin Newsome over there
to talk to shei president I was going to
call him Emperor shei president shei uh
but you know and they were like we're
going to do anything we can to preserve
peace between us but I wouldn't put a
past him to say that and then declare an
invasion that's like stuff Hitler would
have done I saw a video of a guy in
China eating at I think it was a Pizza
Hut and they can stuff the crust with
hot dogs
and when I saw that I was just like
we're doomed you know you know and I'm
and I'm I would I wouldn't say I would
say that's that's 75% a joke the reality
is they are uh uh competing with us in
in a lot of ways that we should be the
best at and I don't literally mean
putting hot dogs in Pizza it's just that
we're giving up our manufacturing only
now in the past several years seem to
have realized that we've given up the in
industry and Manufacturing we need to
maintain an economy and now you're
seeing China's they're they're cranking
away they're burning coal baby just
smogging it up and by the way I'm going
to interview James T at Rice
University's leading graphine scientist
on Earth uh and he they're working on
flash Jewel uh graphine where they hit
carbon trash with lasers and can
produces black powder this stuff this is
the 21st century building material that
we'll need to revolutionize our country
with I don't know though one of them
probably maybe it's just like the
graphine story came out 20 years ago it
was like graphine the Wonder material 20
years ago and so we got some cool stuff
from it but you know I wonder I think
it's really going to come down to the
basics are we producing steel right are
we are are we well I think you can use
you can put this stuff in with like
carbonized steel if you're going to make
it and make it stronger and lighter and
also with um with car with coal like you
were saying we burn coal you can upscale
coal into graphine and burn it cleaner
so there are some I'm I'm very excited
it's going to be uh Friday afternoon so
keep in touch on my Twitter and you can
watch it there so there let
reindustrialize go for it we're say oh I
was just to say I mean I I I want to
believe in science and Innovation I
really do but I get sort of uh a
frustrated with it when ultimately you
know if if graphine is the future maybe
it does I don't I know nothing about it
but is America going to do something
about it or is it going to be China
right like what country is actually most
likely to be ahead in terms of
manufacturing these things and I would
assume it's the country where we put all
of the manufacturing and so in some ways
we've an we've we've uh hamstring our
own ability to embrace innov by shipping
all of these things overseas I mean even
if someone in a lab at a university in
America comes up with something
ultimately the technology is getting
shipped out of the country to develop in
my cynical opinion I would counter that
uh those would become obsolete factories
over there now we'll start building new
ones that focus on flash Jewel creation
if we build them here I'm okay with it I
just don't know that we will well that's
what we're trying to do in Arizona and
places like that where we could actually
have these factories so if that actually
happens and a lot of like the reasons
for taking Taiwan or protecting Taiwan
become secondary to us actually having
the factories back in the United States
that's not all manufacturing though like
China can out manufactur us with like
raw product but when it comes to like
technical manufacturing yeah that's
going to be huge in the next 20 years
biggest place we handicapped in
comparison with China is in in
regulatory framework I mean if you look
at you know how our government hyper
regulates not only the uh the the
industrial side of manufacturing but
then the energy side right and I mean
that's you know my my kind of my
wheelhouse right and that's why we have
you know the the stifling of small
modular reactors and you know we have
companies that American innovators that
are having to take their technology to
Canada and go through the regulatory
board there hoping that the NRC here the
nuclear Regulatory Commission here will
finally open up the gates and allow them
to uh build smrs here and we we're
losing out on
on in every small modular reactor how
does that work um it's essentially you
know it's it's a mini reactor that is
you know mechanically inable mod reor of
melting down you can you can power a
small city with a reactor the size of
this room need no operators and it can't
melt down right cannot melt down what
what kind of what's the fuel source um
still uranium but it's it's it's a too
small passive technology I mean it it it
it doesn't rely on operators the the the
way it's designed I'm no I'm no
physicist or or nuclear engineer but um
you know the the way I understand it is
um the recirculation system the cooling
system they're all you know they're all
passive and reliant on condensation and
and the the systems working in cohesion
with one another so there's no oper
operator manipulation what about Thorium
salt we've heard a lot about that um I
think thorium Salt's another awesome
opportunity for us that we're just I
mean there's there's there's there's
reactors out there that I mean there's
there's ways to convert our retired coal
plants into thorium salt reactors yeah
there's American I used to work for a
guy that invented that um name is Dr
Singh and he introduced it to our
federal government Department of energy
they don't they like why why aren't we
doing these why why are we not doing it
because the money is not going in the
right pocket it's because of Greta
tunberg isn't it that son of she's
hungry for the cash Greta in your
experience how has American how's the
American public's opinion shifted on
nuclear because I feel like that's
ultimately if there were people calling
for it eventually someone would do it
right I mean they're doing it the the
problem is I mean there is a there is a
um a specific Paradigm around nuclear
power people drive by cooling towers and
they think that's the reactor and a lot
of it has to do with the nuclear power
plants not having to Market over the
years they've been in they've been in um
you know regulated environments where
they know they're going to charge a
certain amount per megawatt you know and
and and they're going to get paid
because people have to turn their lights
on but then when you have different
forms of energy that are subsidized by
the federal government that undercut the
market then nuclear becomes well I blame
The Simpsons yeah but for real so this
is actually true Simpsons is considered
to be a factor maybe not the biggest in
why there is resistance to nuclear
energy because people grew up watching
this joke of Springfield of mutated fish
three-eyed fish three-eyed fish Blinky
and meltdowns I think are a theme of a
dozen episodes at least and so people
are consuming media and they're
believing these things are based on
reality they say well every joke has its
truth and it's like no like there
there's not going to be a nuclear plant
so close to you like this it's not going
to blow up you're not going to die there
are less deaths from nuclear power than
from coal and like it's it's exponential
the nuclear power industry is the safest
industry one of the safest Industries in
the country yeah absolutely what's the
biggest misconception about radiation
damage like what I think what happened
is uh when Sher Noble melted down it
just what what all the the spent nuclear
corium or whatever was just there so it
was constantly irradiating the
environment bured into the air and then
you had the Meltdown which created the
elephant's foot and then had they been
able to extract the corium then would it
have no longer been eradiated rting and
it go back to normal I mean if you
remove the source yeah then you would
have no no radiation the problem with
Chernobyl was that when it exploded it
sprayed radioactive uh uh particulates
everywhere which blanketed down over the
region and when when the West was like
Hey Russia what's going on there like
nothing's happening everything's fine
and they're like uh now we're getting
slammed by radiation radio like
radioactive particles so we know
something happened I was thinking about
corium meltdowns corium is like the
stuff in the middle that when it gets
really hot goes and it goes through
cement and it'll just keep melting down
if pour gold into it that it will create
act as a superconductor and allow the
corium to cool itself off and release
the heat so it'll it then it'll Harden
and then you could extract it I'm not
sure that uh gamma rays wouldn't pass
through that I mean if if it could be
x-rayed then you can still have you know
a fision product I would assume I mean
the only real shielding mechanism that
you're going to have from um radiation
of that source is going to be water or
lead or highdensity concrete it wouldn't
be a shield it would just be more to
extract it so you could so it gets out
of it liquid form even then you have to
worry about the dose exposure that
you're going to get as a human you can
only get so much before your internal
organs are going to be you have to send
a robot in to do it I think the biggest
misconception based on my personal
experience is that you're dealing with
gamma wave radiation instead of Alpha
and beta particles right so this is what
I learned when I went to Fukushima they
give me these they give you this cloth
suit to put on and I was like is this a
joke and they were like this is what you
have to wear why you you're they're not
worried about you getting bombarded by
waves that go through everything they're
worried about the particles landing on
your skin which are radioactive and then
you eating them or getting them in your
lungs internal source yeah so so what
what you're you wear these these cloth
suits and then when you're when you're
leaving you take them off very carefully
they BN Bunch them up and throw them in
the garbage we mentioned thorium salt
earlier can you really quickly generally
explain what that is a thorium salt
reactor oh that's kind of out of my
wheelhouse but I know that you know the
thorium salt is essentially heated up
probably through the through the uh
super steam process and then that kind
of creates uh a like a resonating heat
source which then continues to create
the super steam which turns the turbine
right so that really funny that's all it
is yeah we we like we we pressurize a
tube so that it pushes steam which spins
it's kind of simple like I sort of like
that you know one other question it's a
big magnet spin creates octal current
that's there you go so my other question
on nuclear is what about fusion and I
know these get conflated cuz they're not
even remotely the same process but
they're both called nuclear power which
is kind of weird maybe so but what do
you think about Fusion is that even
anything you've ever studied no I mean
you know in my opinion the future again
it goes back to the standard way of of
of of nuclear fion right just having
smaller more manageable less scary to
the public reactors things that you know
take out the human element because
that's really where you've seen these
meltdowns or where you've seen these
close calls what the general public
hasn't been communicated to is like
there was always a safety actuation
system that stopped the general public
from being harmed there's you know what
they call defense in depth there's
always like three to four different
layers of Defense you know with these
nuclear power plants at least in the
United States right Europe has totally
different standards but here in the US
you had Davis besty you had three m
Island I mean we were pretty far away
from actually having a miltown but you
know when it it's uh communicated to the
public it's all about you know scaring
them have you heard of those nuclear
Diamond batteries where they have like
spent nuclear Fuel and they put it
inside of like a diamond and it just
gives you a low pulse of
can you explain that I don't know I've
heard of them but I don't know much I
don't know much give you like 10,000
years of electricity what like a phone
um yeah things like that really really
low charge and then I guess you could
have a lot of them to create a greater
charge but it's actually nuclear waste
inside of a diamond inside of like
carbon that's what we're missing out on
is this recycling of SP nuclear fuel
when this nuclear fuel comes out of the
reactor it's only using 5 to 7% of its
energy potential and we have like
86,000 or you know kilograms or whatever
of of metric tons of spent nuclear fuel
you know sitting in the United States
that we're not using and you have
countries like Europe that are
reprocessing and they're and they're
reusing their spent nuclear fuel we're
throwing it in canisters and leaving it
at the uh nuclear reactors across the
country and that's a multi-billion
dollar industry that we could be opening
and creating high paying jobs high
paying technical jobs for a bunch of
people and we're not doing it and people
don't do it because there's a fear of
nuclear maybe not after tonight we're
changing hearts and Minds over here not
too nuclear d
we just need to bring back that guy from
the Biden Administration the like
non-binary guy who kept stealing luggage
maybe he can save the day he he'd wear a
nuclear diamond ring and become a
superhero took from someone's others
let's uh let's jump to the story we got
a couple political uh bits to jump on we
have the post millennial Trump blasts
attempt to illegally remove his name
from ballot in Colorado on phony
Insurrection claims and ladies and
gentlemen we have received a a a spot in
the books of history at the trial for
Donald Trump Trump over whether or not
he should be allowed on the ballot they
played this clip which I will play for
you now of a show you've probably seen
with cash Patel here we go I have to
wonder cash if everything I said before
about people being too stupid it's in
fact that the leadership is as stupid
right of course the leadership is no no
the leadership is evil they're not
stupid there's a distinction I've worked
with all of these people they are pure
evil the only thing the Pelosi and the
Schumer and and the like care about in
the world is being glorified in the
media that's it what's my next headline
what's my next payday how do I scam the
stock market with my husband how do I
come out on top and be speaker of the
house for more than basically a decade
that is the track that people come in
behind them on and saying I want to be
the next her I want to be the next him
they are evil that's the problem the
people that follow them yeah stupid yep
stupid and they're evil so that was
played that clip it's funny because as
soon as cash said they're evil I laughed
with myself laughing in the clip in the
same way I thought it was hilarious and
shout out to Phil leonti for his cameo
in the in the Trump trial
uh this is the current state of American
politics we have this uh uh this tweet
here from Dean Phillips he says in one
graph this is why I'm running for
president we could be sleepwalking
towards disaster we need an Open Primary
and I hope other qualified Democrats
still jump in here it is from Bloomberg
News morning consult Trump is leading in
five of seven swing States and
Michigan's a tie so you've got in um
Pennsylvania Wisconsin North Carolina
Arizona and Georgia Trump is ahead in
Michigan it's tied in Nevada Biden is
leading in all altogether Trump is Up by
Four Points so why are they trying to
remove Trump from the ballot in
Colorado I think Colorado isn't one of
these states but they want to make sure
that the popular vote count is as low as
possible for Donald Trump and they want
to him they want to uh uh
exhaust his resources and force him into
legal battles the problem however is
this is basically giving Trump a 247
rally I like I get it it's they're
they're trying to stop it by any means
it's necessary but it's like a Chinese
finger trap problem they keep saying
we're going to put him in court then
okay now the media has got a camera in
Trump's face again letting him say
whatever he wants and it makes me think
the people in Colorado whose tax dollars
being spent on this trial right do they
look at this and say yes this is our
biggest priority if you had told me they
were doing something similar in like
maybe 2016 right when people were really
2020 when people were really orange man
bad really freaking out about Trump
maybe I would have said oh yeah the
average Coloradoan feels like this is
the most important use but I don't feel
that way especially postco and
especially since you know Denver in
particular has been really hard hit by
uh illegal immigration there are a lot
of issues that I'm sure people in
Colorado would rather see their
government focusing on and instead this
is what they're being told their
government's number one the legal
apparatus of their government's number
one priority is right now that would
seem just satisfactory for me I don't
know how you feel about it no I I agree
and I think what the American people are
seeing is just a a spending spree by the
B Administration to your point you know
the the average everyday American now is
paying a lot more attention to what's
going on politically and I think Trump
once again resonates with the common
American and you know the two-tier
justice system the guy's been on trial
since 2016 and you know you can only run
it so many times without people paying
some attention and the more they um you
know the more they see it the more drawn
in they are and I I just think Trump has
put on a master class on how to deal
with the media he's put on a master
class on how to deal with these court
systems and he's very transparent and he
speaks his mind and I think PE people
appreciate it I know I do he's
definitely weathered this uh I I would
say there's great words to describe it
but very impressively I would say his
mind is still very clear I can hear the
fatigue but I mean God anyone going
through this would be fatigued I'm just
at the Elmo meme phase in this one you
know that that Elmo with fire rising up
behind him that's where I'm at with this
and I'm like Halloween costume next year
at this point I I really don't care what
Trump says or does I just despise these
people so much that I just want Trump to
go in and do whatever he wants because
it would be the most irritating thing in
the world for them and I know that's how
people felt in 2016 and 2020 I didn't
feel that way 26 and I was like it's all
stupid but there were a lot of people
who were looking at Donald Trump as this
Raging Bull and they were laughing like
I hope this guy gets to do it everyone
I'm at the point where I'm just like I
am so fed up with these trials with
these lies the manipulation just like
can we get two or three trumps can we
get the whole Trump family can we get
where is bar where is an idea we're
constantly trying to figure out who the
VP is going to be Trump trump Trump
trump just do it I don't care which one
it is can you run with your son can your
son be your vice president any one of
them any one of them as long as they're
not from the same state Trump trump but
I don't think they are she's the only
one in yeah well she was North Carolina
I heard rumors that Lara uh La trp might
seriously consider running in North
Carolina because that's where she's from
be VP Trump so interesting just more
trumps I just want I just these awful
people who exploit the system to enrich
themselves through the stock market and
all this awful garbage and then we're
watching them lie cheat and steal
because the American people are finally
like guys you ripped us off for long
enough all we're doing now is saying
Trump's going to build some some border
security and we're going to bring
manufacturing back none of these wars
and y'all couldn't even have it y'all
got away with ripping us off for for
Generations stealing these these these
these ridiculous stock trading Deals
they know what's going on they're
passing the laws they're introducing
them they are lying cheating and
stealing and all we ask is that some
dude gets in for eight little old years
and get us some border security and
bring some manufacturing back and you
said f you to all of us and I'm just
like at this point I just hope it's
Trump 2024 28 32 36 Etc just just never
ending I'm just I'm just so have you
seen the Mel Gibson meme where it's like
me voting for Trump in 2016 is just Mel
Gibson smiling and me voting for no in
2020 and then me voting for Trump in in
24 and it's got you know Mel Gibson with
the
bra that's how the American people feel
man what is it about VI do you guys how
do you feel about VI and what I love him
I do too I love him do you think he like
do you throw your support behind him um
or would you pick Trump do you have a
preference um you know my my loyalties
to to Trump I think he deserves another
four years for all of the reasons we
just said um but you know V I met him a
few years back when you know he wasn't
running for politics he spoke at a
lincol Day dinner locally and uh took a
couple minutes of time to talk to me and
he's he's a guy from Ohio I think he's
uh you know the the young articulate
strong um American Dream type of guy
that we need and he's he could be he
could be VP great I that's what he's he
said he wouldn't take it he said he
wouldn't but he's probably the best
person right now realistically in terms
of POS positioning I would you know it
it it is tough to figure out like who
really would be the best VP but VI
outside of him saying he doesn't want it
probably his best positioned for it I
know I know his team is is is that
that's their Focus right yeah I mean I
talked I talked to his team they're
great people right but I mean you know
the the long game for them they're
they're supporting Trump I mean V is
supporting Trump right he's never bashed
him but's also 38 yeah and I think the
reality he knows he's not going to
defeat Trump right and I think VES uh
intention was to kneecap Rona Sanz in
the debates and he did a hell of job
doing it Well Ron did it to himself I'm
going to say Ron I wanted to love you
dude you went on Patrick Bet David show
where have you been come on man just
relax and sit down and talk to us e
worry he's the governor of Florida in
Florida Patrick P Davids in Miami it was
like I'm not gonna this I'll never do
this right jenier came on the culture
War podcast I say thank you I know you
host your own show taking time off your
your show to do my show is a favor to me
I get it Rhonda Sanz is Inu Florida it's
easy for him to do pbd yeah but you put
in what would it come to fly out here
you put in like eight tops 18 hours of
work you're going to get 700,000 hours
of product out of it from watch I got I
gotta be honest I gotta be honest about
this you I I Patrick Bet David is much
more brutal than I am he he doesn't he
like I I give people leeway and some
people argue I should not yeah you know
a lot of people were saying that when
jener came on the show I should have
just gone at him way heavier and they
were like Why didn't it pop off and I
was like I was trying to prevent it from
getting into that heated debate well and
there were there were a few points where
we talked about George Floyd and Amed
Ary where jent got really heated and I I
pulled away from it trying to keep
things down Patrick bed David the way he
went after Anthony Weiner I mean Ron had
to know that pbd is not going to let him
walk away from the high heel scandal in
this way I got to be honest if Ron came
here I would not drag him I would have
not I would not have done that you
wouldn't have had a set a box of far
shoes like like it was funny it's a it's
a clip viously his team had planned it
even the way he's like phrasing the like
I'm sure you you heard about this thing
like you know this Scandal about your
shoes or whatever like Patrick Davis
knew what he was doing he knew he was
going to do it with second you know he
got santis it's a different style of
show it's not the way you operate no one
who comes on the show will ever be
ambushed like that and I I mean no
disrespect to pbd I think it was
masterfully done and I he's pointing out
great criticism but that's just not how
we would we do things I'm a big fan of
of the work that he does I think he's a
genius but it's funny to me seeing that
I'm like the dandis people are are
banned from coming on this
show but by their own team by their own
team right right yeah yeah yeah we want
them on we want dis and his people to
come on but they've they've refused
they've told their staff they're not
allowed and then he decided to go on
value tment instead where it's like yo
that's the frying pan man that's like
not it's an example of the poor team
that Ronda santz has around I me he's in
he's in an echo chamber right I've met
Ronda santz before I liked him before
the election man I was just thinking
like this guy you know if he would have
done what Reagan you know um did to uh
Barry Goldwater right he could have he
could have passed the torch or not
passed the torch but he could have had
the torch passed to him on the back end
right and he didn't do that and I think
everything about his campaign is a
shining example of the consultant class
ruining Politics the guy has been in an
echo chamber his entire campaign you can
see when he steps out because when he
steps out that's when he's you know out
of his Zone and he makes you know a lot
of mistakes but man dude only if right I
mean he would have been the perfect guy
in 2028 but now it's too late no you
know what I really do think I know I've
said several times in the past couple
weeks but I think the the donors went to
run and convinced him to run to make
sure he would not be VP a trump DeSantis
ticket is unbeatable and that's what
everyone had been saying the year before
you know I've talked about I'll talk you
know I'm talking to a guy I'm hanging
out at MGM National Harbor and there's a
guy he's like I hate Trump oh but I
can't vote for Biden and I'm like what
about desantis's like oh yeah I'd vote
for DeSantis for sure and then I say
what if it's Trump Dan santis Trump
president T FP goes yeah yeah I'd vote
for it he's like with the santis there I
think I could do it and I think the
establishment saw the writing on the
wall that Ron is willing to play ball
with whatever's going to get him the
victory so in Florida he's going along
with with with core right culture War
talking points and he's putting his
policies forward and they're like uh oh
that means that if he teams up with
Trump he's going to just say yes sir to
Trump and he's going to go along with
this to try and be successful and build
and build a career up so they go to Ron
and they say no no you should be
president you should run and they're
laughing at him behind the scenes
they're like this guy's up idiot he's
actually going to do it he thinks he's
going to go up against Trump oh I got an
idea tell him to wear high heels tell
him to wear high heels and then don't
show him the videos and then send him to
pbd on purpose this is the point Jen
yuger comes on this show I basically let
him speak we have a little bit of
disagreements and arguments but there's
a lot of stuff I could have brought up
that we didn't bring up because I'm like
I'm trying to actually talk about
Solutions and keep things T and calm
Patrick B David is is is is he's he's
much more direct he's a lot stronger on
these things than I am with his point of
view anybody who knows about his past
interviews knows he's going he's not
going to let you walk on this one he's
not going to give you the same leeway
that that I might I think they sabotage
him on purpose they they they brought
him to a show and G and and and gave
valut tment a layup to put a pair of
boots on a table oh come on yeah here we
are friends with some of the people who
worked for DeSantis in his campaign and
they they can't even come on the show
and I'm like that's weird man why we
talk to him we'd actually help like hey
let's work through these issues that
you're having and figure out ways you
can improve nah they won't do it yeah
I'd take the boot cut it open on air
with a knife and show you yeah it's a
cowboy boot and it's probably his toes
aren't long enough so it looks like it
was bending still a cowboy boot no you
think he was wearing like inserts cuz
some some cowboy boots just have big
heels fact on my Twitter I posted a
picture of me standing next around the
santis and and a picture of me standing
next to Trump and then Trump standing
next to the santis and in all three
pictures Ronda sz's height has
fluctuated and I don't wear and not
boosters there's when you watch videos
of him walking he's very obviously one
the way he's walking high heels and two
when the foot bends you can tell that M
he's wearing high heels y i someone went
to him and said put the high heels on
you'll look tall and everyone and then
they're laughing at him like I can't
believe this idiot's doing it and he
won't fire these people because they are
sabotaging him on purpose and this now
again the Trump sandis ticket a year and
a half ago was unbeatable absolutely
they'd be Trump if Trump announced
sandis would be the VP he'd be pulling
it 52% or something honestly if if the
sers just bowed down and had humility
right now they'd still be
unbeatable if you saw him acknowledged
the the I don't want to swear on camera
but the last year of his campaign if he
acknowledged how poorly run it was
people would light up I think that
there's uh too much animosity right now
for a a trump disantis ticket and I
think part of it has to do with the
infrastructures they're both surrounded
by because you would need to merge their
teams or one of them would have like do
Sanz would have to abandon everyone he's
been working with I don't know that
that's realistically going to happen
maybe it should so I I don't want to
force anyone into drama but why is it
that there have been three people who
have come on this show who have asked me
why am I being attacked by desantis's
campaign and so there are individuals
who are not
individuals whose careers do not put
them in the line of I'm for Trump or I'm
for we've had people on the show who are
not saying either of those things and
they're like the San campaign started
attacking me and I'm like yeah they're
trying to destroy his campaign they want
to make they're going scorched Earth
they want to make sure that if in six
months it clearly is Trump there will
not be a recovery period like Ted Cruz
had Ted Cruz was lying Ted and then
after the primary he was Ling Roar Ted
lying instead of lying that's pretty
good the recovery that's pretty good
insight he his sadness beard that was a
time well I can speak to that too right
look what uh you know when when this
first all started I I wasn't uh negative
on the santis at all and and I'm known
to be a trump supporter right but then
you had JD Vance come out and say you
know leave it to Ronda santis is poorly
run team to attack their former friends
right and that's exactly what they've
done but but see the thing is they
attacked people who were currently their
friends yeah I like I've had people
prominent individuals say to me I they
like ask me like hey uh you know what's
going like I'm being attacked by the sis
people do you know why and I'm like I'm
like they are attacking everybody and
it's just they're just like I I don't
understand like I've not said anything
bad about him at all right and I'm I
just I think the idea is after the
primary they want to make sure that not
a single Trump supporter will welcome D
santis back yeah there's no explanation
for why some of these personalities are
prominent individuals with a lot of
followers there's no explanation for why
they're like I can't stand a STIs you
know I'm why would you attack some of
these people like why did they start
attacking us why did they ban their
people from coming on the show if what
when Ron loses there's a recovery period
where Trump can say enough fighting you
know Ron's a great governor and we're
going to welcome him back not anymore
there's not he's going to be Rosie oon
yeah exactly it is so toxic and the high
heels thing was the nail in the coffin
there's no way Trump can be like I'm
going to choose backstabbing high heel
Ron with the crackhead PR team it's it's
not it's not gonna happen there's a
reason why they don't work for Trump
anymore and they deflect it over to his
team I mean y to Santa's crew yeah oh
okay he has some smart people on his
team but I don't think so they're
they're not around anymore though they
may intelligent maybe they're just not
wise no
no two potentials desantis's people are
geniuses and what they're doing is
intentionally destroying Dan santis or
they are the stupidest people in the
world and they don't understand they're
destroying to San additionally no matter
how you cut it r santis is the dumbest
politician in the country right now for
hiring it's firing them look look you
can you can hire bad people but after
the first scrup you have a talking to
after the second scrup you start saying
warning and you put out statements third
scrup you say I have removed this person
from my staff he's not done it
especially when your platform is built
on the you know the the preface that you
run a tighter ship than Trump right
Trump had all these leaks in the white
houses according to disantis and he runs
a tight ship in Florida right it just
it's a it's a it's a direct uh polar it
it's it's polar to what he what he's
campaigned on yeah I get the vibe okay
what I was going to say I think I Ron
strikes me is high intelligence low
wisdom because he doesn't know how to
get his intellect across it's poorly
managed and poorly integrated and like
you got to have humility dude and this
this obsession with pride of like oh
they said something mean get them like
no you got to like roll with it yeah you
said something mean cuz I'm a goofball
sometimes that's his team yeah see I
likeed into like his Persona
unfortunately you're right I like Ronda
Sanz I think he's done the best job of
any governor in Florida and that's why
so many people moved there that's why a
lot of people are defensive of him but
that is it that is no excuse for hiring
the worst people imaginable who are
setting fires to everything around you
and you being like this is fine at that
point I'm like this guy has a very
serious leadership problem very serious
leadership and I'm you know what I'm
going to start doing sorry I can only
assume now the accomplishments of
Florida are to the legislature and he's
just going true I guess and he's he's
bumbling around like Mr meoo because
where he has direct executive Authority
his campaign he's failed miserably when
it comes to the politics of Florida he's
stamping with the Florida legislature
passes and so we give him a lot of
credit for it and for standing up and
making statements now I'm just thinking
you know they're probably just handing
him a script and he just says whatever
and in Florida they want to win they do
but here they're trying to tank him
knowing he can't beat Trump and they
don't want him teaming up with Trump so
they're sabotaging him or they want him
to stay governor of Florida and they
don't want him to be president so
they're trying to destroy his chances I
don't know that's a possibility it's not
it's not a great uh any of these offics
are prettyy bad to have on your staff
right I mean this is not what you would
want to be surrounded by while running a
campaign yeah I mean but the
establishment to Tim's point is evil and
they'll you know they'll go to the
farthest lengths to destroy something
that they don't like well people were
pointing out like Ken Griffin donating
to Des santis and the immediate
assumption is the establishment is
teaming up with the santis to go against
Trump and I'm kind of like or they just
are sabotaging to STIs they do not want
an ascendant to Trump personality they
don't want an heir to the Trump Throne
if what was everybody saying Trump 2024
DeSantis VP DeSantis 2028 not anymore
they're not the sandz is done I mean I
don't know where he goes after this he's
he's termed out of Florida maybe he'll
Run for the Senate so question then VP
ramas Swami or Kennedy Ram Swami ramas
Swami I personally want Larry Elder to
be VP I've got a job writing on it so
you know I like Byron Donalds to be
honest yeah Byron's a good guy I love
Byron
a really cool dude stand up guy he's
endorsed my campaign by the way um but
yeah Byron Donald is is one of the best
people I met in DC I agree absolutely
one of the best people I I mean there's
there's so few people but I actually met
Byron Donald's when he was hanging out
with Matt Gates and I'm like I'm not
surprised like these are good dudes
Lauren boer's office we interviewed him
it was really cool do you think that
there's any weight to the idea that
Trump's going to feel obligated to pick
a female VP oh he better not play this
game that's what I do not want him to
play this game but I keep hearing
everywhere no it's definitely going to
be a woman definitely going to be woman
and I do not want that it makes me
really mad be sure to tell him that I
think yeah as soon as he calls me I'll
be like if you put pick a woman bpv
you've lost everyone's confidence we got
you know you know like people kept
asking us when we're having him on the
show and we know so many people in Trump
Circle they've all said like we can
figure something out we'll talk to him
he's he'll probably just say yes of
course but we got to go to him and we
just we've not coordinated it and tried
to make it happen I'm not saying Trump
is going to give us the time of day I'm
saying you know a lot of people around
them are like no no yeah we can we can
can work with him and and and schedule
something we've just not done it we
should probably just finally do it and
just get our like booking people to be
like can we just arrange this finally
because then I can say you know Don just
don't no no no Nicki Haley like yeah I
think that should let me let me ask you
I I think you know what I've learned in
politics is things kind of uh are plated
right on purpose I think maybe that was
something that leaked on the back end to
just test the waters for what the
general public would think and what
Twitter would think and I think pretty
quickly it got uh you know smashed that
you know he he needed to have a a female
vice president and I think he's I think
he's turned the page on that I don't
think VI is the perfect candidate I
think he's the current best option you
know in the past I said Carrie Lake but
you know there were several points that
were made one in terms of what is best
for Cary Lake running for Senate winning
in Arizona and helping fix the states we
got to win at the state we got we got to
win win the states
um but also some other people pointed
out then you have Trump and Trump
basically Carri lake is a smart like no
disrespect to Trump but she is a a a a
sharper articulate Trump and so people
have said you need a contrast to that
and VI in a way is kind of like Trump
but he's a PR guy he is tactful kind of
like how car lake is but I'm in terms of
his presence that's why I kind of feel
like he's probably the better option
sometimes I want it to be a VP that is
not currently seeking the presidency you
know I know that's pretty normal to to
consider you know this how we got uh
Camala Harris of course but I think P
wasn't running right Pence wasn't
running and and again like not that
Pence was notar option Pence was forced
by The Establishment man I mean that's
that's given but I don't like it
becoming too much of a of a
manufacturing line right it's like well
if you drop out early enough I'll give
you a VP I like the idea that there is
potentially other perspectives out there
that we don't hear on the national I
think I think V compliments Trump in the
fact that they have two totally
different leadership Styles I mean
Trump's a transformational type guy
right he sees the big picture of a tends
to get in the details and you know they
they um they're Polar Opposites in so
many regards but personality wise they
do have some similarities yeah they're
both executiv I but Trump has the is the
executive and ramaswami is The
Mastermind yeah they're both masterminds
but ramaswami is a pure Mastermind yeah
I mean that's what he said when he was
here he was saying you know some
personalities just can't mesh well
together and I a personality I've been
an executive for so long like I have to
be at the front and I think it might be
a challenge to be VP under someone else
it's not that he's not talented and
could do amazing things it's just it's
just hard for me to imagine a trump R
ramaswami ticket where they're both
happy at the end of I think it's he has
a duty to the country I think we all do
and if he's called to the position he
has to take it Trump can persuade him I
mean you know that that that's the
that's the beauty of the guy you know
you sit down with him I get it right
certain personalities Clash but if it's
not you know obvious that those two
could work in cohesion I mean just
someone who understands leadership
Theory at a basic minimum can tell that
these two guys can work together because
they balance one another I'm just kind
of thinking like who else could it be
seriously I
mean though that's think it be Ken
Kennedy now Kennedy to your point that's
where I think there would be a
Personality Clash because I don't think
Kennedy's going to take the back seat
and where you have a guy like Byron who
was also technically intelligent right
with his Finance background there's
another balance to Trump so I mean you
have to kind of look for that
personality uh subtle differences but
differences that compliment I think I
think Byron maybe in a couple Cycles
would it's tough I don't see him as a VP
right now byon Donald is he running is
he running for he doesn't have any
aspirations we should have him on the
show we we only interviewed him for like
15 minutes he was only on for like 10 or
15 minutes make sure Larry comes with
him his buddy his buddy Larry his his
adviser those two together are it's
hilarious man they're great I would love
to talk to Byron for a couple hours VI
seems
like he could be VP right now but again
I don't think he's the perfect candidate
it's just I don't know who else there is
unless it was Trump trump which I don't
think would be realistic as much as I
jokingly say let's just get as many
trumps in federal office and as possible
let's just you know how how old is is
Baron can he run for Congress yeah he's
got to be 25 not old enough Baron Trump
he hasn't graduated high school yet I
mean he's he's got a minute I think I'll
make an exception to put more trumps in
in government just get them all in there
because it off runs for class president
then he will run 1 we're going to get
accused of uh7 promoting oligarchy on
the show right care Trump royal family
because it pisses off the machine and
then we'll we'll figure out it's it's
like The Simpsons when you know when
they had the the the what do they have
the lizard problem and so they were like
they'll get dogs and then how do you do
with the dogs and then they like we'll
get you know they increase keep getting
the animals bigger and bigger until
they're finally like we'll have gorillas
Go and Kill the animal and then they're
like but then they have a gorilla
problem and Skinner I think it was
Skinner is like no that's the best part
when winter comes they simply freeze to
death so it's just like we'll get all
the trumps in there let them just just
trump it out trump it out man and then
you know we'll figure it out later I
thought you made a good point that R
Swami is not the perfect candidate
because I think a lot of people might
right now be looking for Perfection and
if they don't see it they're going to
turn away and vote for what they think
is safe but you're never going to find
perfection you've got to go with you got
to take risks and to to to counter that
though if you look at some of the folks
that are anti Viv that are in like Maga
you know in the Maga mindset right
they're they're attacking VI because
they believe he's too perfect they think
he's OB Obama 2.0 I mean there's a lot
of different theories on that but at the
end of the day like it's it's Deeds not
words right and if you look at what V
has done for his personal life for his
family you know for the state he lives
in his community I mean you don't have
any V ramaswami employees jumping out
saying this guy's a terrible leader V
effectively said he wants to cut funding
to Israel now not as blunt he says he
wants to get them sustainable to the
point through US support to where we
don't need to be supporting them anymore
which is the intelligent way of saying
like hey we should not be that's bold
because you know Nikki Haley is like she
loses her mind my objection to Ron SW to
be honest is you know again I'm very
lucky to be in the position haven't got
to ask him this but he has he has a more
flexible view on hb1 H1B visas than I do
I I feel like I would prefer someone to
take a stronger stance on border and
border security and and reducing even
legal immigra legal immigration into the
country as well as illegal immigration
but that is not to say that he couldn't
do amazing things I am not convinced
this is the cycle I don't think he would
like being VP to Trump but he has
incredible potential and I think it's
better to have a a a deep bench of
people who can do good things for the
country even like we always talk about
it like it's just the presidency in the
VP but it's really not there are tons of
cabinet positions there are lots of
things that we could have talented
intellectual and accomplished people
people uh step into and really benefit
the American public I get the uh the
Obama criticism they they they feel like
via is Obama 2.0 I've thought that a
couple times I've even said it on the
show VI the snake I called him a couple
times and it's like I feel that like
he's an order he's willing to bend with
the wind like a re even to the point
maybe where he'll snap like Obama did
and then the big business takes over but
that's why I like seeing him in a VP
position because he'll watch it happen
all around him and he won't have to be
the one getting co-opted and you'll see
how Don like kind of came out on SC
that's he communicated to us he didn't
want to be someone watching he wants to
be at the head of the organization and
so again like maybe if you know he
doesn't progress with the presidential
race maybe he should run for governor of
Ohio maybe he should step into a
leadership role on a smaller scale and
then you know he's so young he has so
much potential to do a lot of things if
he doesn't run this cycle I'm sure he'll
run again who do the Democrats have in
terms of Youth
AOC and like Max Frost that's like the
guy you're always talking about he's
like the young gav new yeah but X Frost
you said yeah I that's I think that's
his name Florida he's not the same level
of AOC and not yet VI like stepped onto
the stage and hit it out of the ballpark
and and Skyrocket in terms of uh just
like notoriety notability you know the
things he was saying the conversations
was having the way was having them
inspired a lot of people very very
quickly and resulted in this viral like
notability yeah the guys loved in Ohio
like I said man I met him before he even
had political aspirations he was just
coming around
talking about I mean he was he was a
Libertarian you know he said it some
some people are arguing have made the
claim that he wants to be a senator out
of Ohio I think he's denied that yeah I
mean there's been people advocating for
it you know because of the senate race
in Ohio right now is is highly contested
so you know I think V standing out the
way he has during his presidential run
has drawn a lot a lot more attention to
him when uh when Gavin new some went
over to China I got the vibe like oh
they're running Gavin Nome that's what's
going to happen so I I now
that should I I I just I can't identify
with Democrats at all because if I were
like this guy wants to be the president
so he went to China and that's how I
know he wants to be the president like
no no no T the US leave California and
come see you know industrial towns in
the midwest that were devastated by
manufacturing leaving go to West
Virginia and talk to people who are
affected by the opioid crisis like if
you want to be president of the United
States shouldn't you talk to Americans
why would you be like I will go overseas
this is a great idea I just I can't
relate to it spank little boys while I'm
playing basketball I've never seen a
governor go speak with the president of
China before have you I've never seen
that before it weird huh yeah that was
highly uh unique unorthodox yeah novel
you know the great nation of California
needs representation in China I don't
see Biden being the nominee I don't see
him being the candidate for the
Democrats yeah because look at the polls
right now Jen yuger said he's only
running basically to bring awareness to
that the fact that Biden's going to lose
and that he's like what I have have to
run because people don't understand
Biden will lose he bought the domain
Biden is goingt lose.com oh that's
hilarious like and he said Republicans
should want Biden in the race and I'm
like I agree well and then and then um
Dean Phillips out of Minnesota launched
his campaign to challenge Biden after
pretending he wasn't going to for a
minute yeah he's to the Tweet we pulled
up it's it's kind of interesting that
we're we have a an open Democrat who's
like I'm I'm I think I could maybe run a
race uh I I had thought when RFK decided
to run as an independent perhaps there
was pressure from the DNC being like you
have to get out of here we can't have
anyone else but obviously that message
hasn't hasn't trickled down to the rest
of the rank and file if we have someone
out of Minnesota saying well I might
throw my hat in the ring after we've
already have an independent candidate
challenging essentially Biden I know
they pretend like it's both Trump trump
and Biden it's really not I mean no one
wants Biden to run this is what's
happening I was a I didn't I wasn't here
when chank was on the show uh because I
was in Miami but I was thinking about
progressivism that's a term that gets
thr I'm Progressive thing about
progressivism and I'd love to talk to CH
to talk to you about this directly too
chank progress means to move forward so
you can progress towards a cliff and
then walk off the cliff where are you
progressing that's a big part of being
Progressive what are you progressing to
and also how are you progressing are you
progressing as a wild mob disorganized
or are you progressing in an organized
fashion they're they're they're marching
towards the cliff and we need to we need
to that needs to be discussed debated
and observed because that's a big part
of you can't just say you're Progressive
and so you don't want to be regressive
but unless well it depends if you're
about to walk off a cliff you do want to
be regressive or maybe you want to turn
left what's the what's transgressive
transgressive yes we're the
transgressive is is that the right word
transgressive we don't want to go
forward the forward is the cliff we
don't want to go backwards that's too
far but we want to go kind of back and
to the left you know we should go back a
little bit because the left has gone
nuts but we mostly just want to turn
left maybe degressive or turn right I
want to go back into the right I was
going to say I will only join this
movement the transgressive movement if
we're going back into the right
transgressive I'm into the transgressive
movement then but back into the left
sounds equally as bad because ultimately
it'll be like why were we going back we
should go forward again and it'll just
horseshoe back to where it was going we
do have the 20s in the chat for what Ian
had said because it is correct the the
left seems to be Progressive for the
sake of progress but progress for the
sake of progress is blind they're just
saying just keep doing it keep doing it
why not why not and you're like
eventually you're like hey there's a
naked man dancing in front of children
and they're like progress and you're
like okay but this is not what we
thought we were progressing to
transgress we want Star Trek and like
you know replicators and cold Fus stuff
and graphine not naked men dancing for
children okay that's not progress that's
something weird actually I think that's
transgressive Amen brother amen sister
that's what I meant no I think I think
progress in the in the relative sense
like what would Americans view as
progress it would
be space travel uh you know uh um
colonizing other planets when you ask
someone what do you think the future
looks like these are the things they
they they Envision they Envision oh
people aren't hungry anymore people
aren't starving food replicators
spaceships that's what they think of
when they think of us advancing and
progressing what's happened is the left
has hijacked progress and now they've
got naked dudes dancing in front of
children and I'm like okay that's that's
like veering off the course yeah so so
we're driving here a better way to put
it we're driving on this road and you've
got a rocky Cliff side to your right and
a sheer Cliff side straight drop to your
left and they've they've turned the car
to the left and we're like guys if we
keep keep this angle up we're going off
the edge we got to correct it and go
back to the the the dreams of of what we
used to focus on for a moment let us
Congress meaning move together and turn
around and then we'll go to space but
now so we Define where we're going very
clearly paint the picture chank and
everyone that wants to be Progressive or
consider himself paint the picture of
where you want to end up I like this
word Gress yes currently we should
egress yes we're about to egress the
super chats but also after you explain
where we're going and you you outline it
in such a vivid way that people can
picture it then explain how we're going
to get there piece by piece and you'll
have a lot of people following
you yeah see the left is mostly just we
should just do what we do for whatever
reason which is the military war machine
from 1913 Federal Reserve banking yeah
it's the Never Enough party right they
say you know we've accomplished this
Progressive goal but now we have to push
it and we there there's no there's no
reason why it's just continuing to push
boundaries forward and forward and I
think that allows people with really
nefarious agendas to step in and say I'm
benefiting from this kind of this this
dissolve into
chaos Anarchy you know disguises as
progressivism in so many different ways
I mean true progressivism like like
you're explaining I mean is realistic it
has reasonable goals and you you know
where you're going with them I mean it's
just total Destruction that's what
transgressive means actually means just
violate the social norms or regular
Norms that we're doing so really in
reality they are transgressive because
that's the definition of the word
they're not progressing towards anything
that's meaningful and the goal poost are
always moving too close every day
transgressor if you're like swerving the
wheel left and right as you're going
stop it uh oh Serge's got the details
yeah it's like it has to do with like
breaking social boundaries or moral
boundaries yeah so transgressive would
be to like end like revolting against
moral and social boundaries which was
literally what the Progressive Movement
today is saying that they're doing so
creating Generations oh yeah trans
transgressive is involving a violation
of moral or social boundaries yeah
exactly so that's what I was saying like
they're literally are transgressive
because what they always tell me is that
that they're trying to do is like you
know subvert the thing so it's not it's
like you're not Progressive Progressive
is the wrong word and I don't know
they're transgressive transgressive like
Progressive they're arguably aggressive
unfortun very aggressive very aggressive
Ian has just now stated every word using
the using the bass Gress and if you have
yet to Ingress do it it's in prayer you
you'll go within yourself feel God's
energy you should write a song that
where use all these Gress words Gress on
gresser yes I
[Laughter]
guess okay how about we uh pop over to
Super Chat so happy we progress over to
don't Bey no we Ingress yeah we are all
right if you haveen already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends head over to
timcast.net uh Joey boy was that before
after he issued the surrender
man that was probably uh after Alpha
turkey says hey Tim it's unfair for you
to call Jen Z lazy for not wanting to
get out of bed to work when your
generation didn't have to deal with the
possibility of a Disney executive under
your bed it's a fair point Kathleen
Kennedy was not under my bed that's a
reference to South Park by the way
Cartman's like Mom can you check see
Kine Kennedy's under my bed and then uh
I don't want to spoil the rest for
you no but I think um I think
Millennials are lazier than gen Z I
think it's important to say you know I I
I I want to make sure I have this I say
this quite a bit gen Z actually is I
think in many ways based and Millennials
suck I think a lot of it is that they
aren't incentivized and so there is no M
the momentum's not there it's just they
they wake up to this like what's the
point kind of thing that I didn't get in
the 90s and the 80s I was like I'm going
to be a rockstar I'm going to be an
actor I'm going to be famous make a
bunch of money and save the world yeah I
think a lot of Millennials were trained
to just wait for instruction you know
and so now that's what happens they're
just W for someone to tell them what
they're supposed to be doing and they're
frustrated because they're not satisfied
with that way of living and what happens
with Gen Z is they catch the beginning
of the influencer age in which you have
to build your own platform so
Millennials were like tell me what to do
Mom and Dad tell me what to do teacher
tell me what to do professor and that's
their whole life and they get a got a
college get out of college and they're
like government please govern Me Harder
daddy whereas gen Z are in this period
where tons of people are self-made young
people are self-made Millionaires and
they're like I got to I got to hustle
and I got to make a page and I got to do
these influencer stuff now not all that
is good but I think that creates a
little bit more of an Entre
entrepreneurial and independent Spirit
among gen Z don't don't get me wrong
there are a lot of Communists in gen Z I
wonder if that's natural generational
that you you breed generations of
workers and then generations of leaders
that then build businesses for the
workers it remind me of uh nature versus
nurture is what it is see it reminds me
of like year of the I don't remember
what it's called in China I guess the
zodiacs but like zodiac the year of the
is it the dragon is the year that
everyone wants to have a kid there's one
year where a lot of people are like this
is this is the best thing ever and I was
listening some report from NPR where
it's like the children who are born in
this desirable year actually do perform
better on tests they do tend to have
higher education you know things like
that these metrics but that's because
they're dragons well and that's the
thing are is it because they are told
constantly you're successful you're
special both or is it because people
just say oh yes the dragon like that is
very important you must you must be
stand out I they're literally dragons
personally you think they're literally
dragons yeah I'm a monkey I'm you're
you're the monkey I think I'm a tiger
nice know my high school animal the
Tigers The Falls tigers tiger Falls
what's up I don't know what I am
somebody show tell me I'm April 2nd 1979
it's per year so whatever 79 would be so
I'm 92 some monkey Chinese yeah Chinese
1986 tiger tiger and it means each of
these years come with different
attributes I mean I find this really
interesting right I'm the
goat's joke you're 79 I'm 79 man what's
up goat
yeah oh wow that's what I'm talking
about goats represent what's what's
yours Han clir I think I'm the pig or
something damn 95 I have no idea what it
is 95 is the uh the blind molrat well
that's F you are the pig yeah you're
you're a pig I was going to make a c
possible reference I didn't know if any
of the boys in this room
sometimes translated as the boar yeah
that's me I'm a boore 93 is the rooster
dude roosters are cool yeah the roosters
are based we got um all the rooster boys
we got too many so we created an outside
area so it's outside of chicken City
it's not the chicken City suburbs and
we' it's the area that's fed off and we
there's a little house there's like a
little a little makeshift house so they
can go in there and be safe from the
wind and there's like 12 roosters and
they're just outside exposed not going
in they're just so dumb and they've just
huddled together for warm I'm like guys
go in your little shelter and they they
stop telling me what to do I'm an
independent chicken I rallied them
earlier I rallied them for those that
were listening to chicken City uh at
chicken city.com I think chicken City
live.com I rallied them and and made
sure they knew that these young men
these brave men are the front line to
protect the city of of chicken City from
predators raccoons and foxes they got to
get through these these Brave roosters
before they can make it into the city
where the civilians are at wow arousing
speech that's
right one year in the future the
struggle all right Stephen says
congratulations at bla Kaiser you are
first that's right he was first Raymond
g stany j says Tim look at you out here
making the January 6 hearing and now
Trump's trial before you know it you'll
be on trial yourself shout out Phil's
Cameo yep you know it's kind of a weird
thing like I didn't start doing this so
that clips of me would end up at January
6 hearings or in Trump's ballot hearing
trial but it is going to be hilarious in
like a 100 years and they're like kids
open up the archive and let's watch a
clip from timcast IRL a political show
and we'll learn about the politics of
the era and it's like I don't know me
and Ian saying stupid nonsense things
and making jokes about fat pigs and like
it insulting Liz chain when President po
was a child he started a building
computers at the age of 12 it'll be
funny cuz it's like the there's so much
advertising I wonder anyone else like
who was in the courtroom that day or
whatever if they're going to be like I
never heard of this show it's kind of
interesting Tim Cass like how many
listeners do we have tonight who in the
courtroom all the news articles are
right about it no yeah in the future
they're not going to mention president
pool they're going to be talking in
class about you know a former
president's appearing on the show and
then one student's going to be like how
come we don't hear about Tim pool and
any other history books I'm like Ah
that's because shortly after this he got
into a van and went to live down by the
river that's how it that's how'll turn
out the Avatar needed him most he was
gone that's right for 100 years yeah
where I envisioned myself ending up is
like an old 65-year-old man on the top
of a mountain with a bunch of chickens
and you know a nice little RV or
something to live in self self-
sustainable and you know a pointy stick
and when someone shows up being like
we'd like to talk to you get out my
property get away from me you crazy
people I don't want have anything to do
with you leave me alone they be like wow
this guy went crazy it's like yes he
did uh all right where we at voice of
the people says since they played that
clip of you and cash Patel in court does
this mean everyone must be removed from
trial remember juror 77 they're all
far-right extremists now that's right
yeah juror 77 remember that in Trump's
case he had once seen an episode of
timcast and therefore they said he's
biased gotta go well now clearly after
that uh everyone in that trial saw that
clip of me of course they're fans does
this mean that I will never have to
serve jury jury jury duty yeah like oh
well occasionally I'm on this podcast
get out of here no no but yeah wow
that's so well I guess I can never use
an excuse to call if if I I believe it
is fair to say that if you went to jury
duty if you got summoned and you showed
up and they they ask you be like I am a
political personality and pundit and
writer for a big publication I appear on
a live show every night they'd be like
you're dismissed they'd be like no
you're not that get out of here you
think you're famous well because you
read the news every single day that I
think that right there is like for my
job I do nothing but read the news it
would be impossible for me to not know
about what's going on in this case yeah
I think so y yeah it's like one one
aspect well no it's more than one aspect
of the news that's crazy I may never
served jury duty if I get asked that's
what I'm definitely going to say no this
is a problem you want to be on jury duty
yeah I'm not against it it's just like a
crazy thing to think you know when you
make choices in life that the problem is
something up the people who aren't smart
enough to get off jury duty are the ones
who get jury duty yeah true you you I I
always wanted to go on jury duty I never
got I've never got summoned for jury
duty i' I'd love to be there and be like
not guilty and they'll be like but sir
he had the marijuana on him it's like we
have it I'd be like not guilty and
they'd be like but he confessed I'd be
like I don't think you heard me now
you're definitely for jury duty oh for
sure you know the um was that 12 Angry
Men or whatever that movie was where
like all the jurors and they're trying
to convince them I would be the one guy
and they' they'd be like well we all
think this guy's guilty of possession
I'd be like not guilty and they'd be
like they've recovered the evidence he's
admitted to having it he's made a silly
excuse I'm like not guilty then one by
one the only argument I have is it
shouldn't be illegal and then I'll be
like so I'll just keep saying it over
and over again until y'all say not
guilty that's why I'd like to be on jury
duty now you never can like this is
really blowing my mind now I never can
I'm never going to be able to serve on a
jury when you're strong Fain weakness
all you have to do if you never want to
serve jury duty is say a simple
sentence if ever selected for jury duty
I will nullify in every circumstance
done I like jury nullification it should
be used
but they they they'll they'll arrest you
there's been activist outside of Courts
advocating for journal ification and
they arrest you for it CU they're like
you can't do this but the jurors
themselves can do it and they won't get
messed with so I it's it's it's
interesting because yes you as the jury
have ultimate power in deciding whether
or not someone is guilty but what they
do is they'll say you are not allowed
they'll be like you must disregard your
personal feelings the only question that
matters is so I'll give you an example
Illinois uh two houses one was asked to
watch over their neighbor's house
neighbors went on vacation it was a
small town the police knew that this
family was on vacation the kid went in
the back door open the fridge to steal a
beer he was like 18 or something I say
kid he's a man cops driving by saw the
light on knowing the family wasn't there
approached the house freeze ah you're
under arrest what are you doing and he's
like ah like you're robbing this house
when it went to the uh uh Court he he
said the families were all like we don't
care they took a beer we we told them
they could watch the house and they're
like like nope it's it's burglary it's
it's it's theft and then a judge was
like there's a mandatory sentence for
this it doesn't matter what you think or
what the state is Prosecuting so then he
said we'll go to trial then at trial
they were like uh it doesn't matter to
the jury what you think is right what
matters is was the law broken he did not
have permission to go in and take from
the refrigerator which is burglary which
is theft so he must be found guilty if
those are if if you agree with those
facts you must find him guilty and they
went I I guess right they could have
said no not guilty because it's it's a
poor execution of the law so you nullify
the case yes and the judge apparently
something happened where the judge was
like I'm not sending this kid to prison
over this are you insane and then the
prisons were like we are not accepting
this person are you insane and there's
like just it's Illinois is an evil place
I'll put it that way I'm probably like
butchering the story because it's been
20 years but that's like the gist of it
that everyone was just like why is this
guy going through the system this way
the jurors were like why are we
convicting this guy and everyone's like
Bo but you have to but the reality was
the jurus could have been like I don't
care what you say you think's notty yeah
I feel like it's weird to be in a
circumstance where you're like okay
suspend all of your values and make a
decision like how could you possibly
separate yourself from that actually
that's like being a judge I was spending
time with a girl that has been studying
Lauren de Laguna what's up uh for
getting her she passed the bar and has
studied law and the impartiality is
fascinating of being a judge you just
like I know the law that is a violation
of it continue stop you're violating it
stop continue and that's it doesn't
matter what you think what you feel just
the knowledge is present I get that for
being a judge but for a juror It seems
impossible to ask that guy Soka says
greetings from Fremont Ohio Tim we love
you here and we have Jr's back and his
bid to be our rep make Northwest Ohio
great again awesome right on AA Baka
says I imagined Ian returning saved by
Jesus Christ more swole and running sub
5sec drills rifle pistol drills oh I
didn't even mention it Luke rudowski had
me out to Tactical training twice and
it's I would I would suggest anyone no
first aid no we did knife practice and
then we did a lot of shooting and stuff
and what's great about it is once you do
it once you start to train you don't
have to think about it anymore you just
are able to react in those situations
that's and it's kind of like I was like
oh I don't want to go back and talk
about World War III and all this crap
but it's like what I'm doing is I'm
training it's like tactical training for
my mind muscle memory yeah and and so
this the the the metaphor of doing both
the weapons training and the knowledge
training of knowing about this horror is
is like I don't have to think about it
now that I know I can just react to the
system but I highly recommend tactical
training and having some weapons
training if you have an
opportunity all right Paul tascal says
new Theory when a 2024 Trump Victory is
apparent Democrats will admit they did
steal the election from Trump in 2020
and therefore he can't be elected in
2024 because it would mean he'd get
elected for a third term well what they
would say is you can't get elected a
third time not term but yeah definitely
not going to happen but funny wipo IRL
says Kennedy is going to win against
Nikki Haley and Dean Phillips Trump is
going to spend the week of the
convention in house arrest Biden can't
walk how is he going to run the election
is the Dark Horse
election it would be really funny if
just like two months before the election
some random person no one's ever heard
of just appears and just gets all the
support I was picturing like they they
give people like a trophy at the end of
the at the end of the track and they're
like okay you guys got to run whoever
gets that going to be president and
they're like literally just comes down
to you got to run for president well we
know who would trip and fall over their
own
feet dude we need a strong Commander man
yeah we do yes I Trump the only guy man
I'm telling you I mean I think we all
agree with that but he's he's absolutely
the guy that we need right now we need
to cauterize a lot of things yeah and
he's the match that's going to do it I I
firmly believe it all right William
trash says timy and my girlfriend's dog
Leo was put down today he would have
been 14 in January she would really
appreciate it if you guys could say a
few words he was a good boy Leo wasn't
just a good boy he was the best of boys
and we mourn his passing for Every Good
Boy is a best friend Leo spirit is still
here uh witnessing you and um he will be
for a while and then he'll go off and
he'll be he'll be back he'll be back
with you he's going to evolve too he's
going to come back and inhabit something
greater thank
you all all right well sorry to hear
William sorry to hear uh but but uh
condolences all right riding with Ryan
says I saw the movie We Were Soldiers as
a kid pretty young for the movie but not
too young I've grown up strongly against
War yeah how about Saving Private Ryan
yeah we going is that brutal enough
platoon what else PL pretty jacket Metal
Jacket Metal Jacket yeah apocalypse now
just have your have your six-year-old
kids watch Full Metal Jacket I'm kidding
nobody says anything like okay I guess
they'll think basic training is cool
till they get there uh Total Recall have
your kids all watch Total Recall yeah
it's pretty the original one not the
Remake the original one when his eyes
are about to explode from his head and
the lady has three boobs
yep don't make him like they used to all
right all right Ben says protest
happening in Minneapolis started at 6
pm. central time they were chanting from
The River To The Sea we will never be
free I I is that what they're how do you
even chant that if you will never be
free what well they chant from The River
To The Sea Palestine will be free
there's like this is a rhythm to it
right from the river to the Sea we will
never be free is that how you do it be
extended there must be I don't know if
this is perfectly paraphrased here yeah
we will never be free I don't know about
that we will be
free we will never be free we will never
yeah I don't know why why You' say that
I don't know why you PR say that I'm
sure they're being misquoted but who
knows maybe not Jason barar says I think
War should be put up to a vote for the
from the people and if you vote in favor
of War you get put at the front of the
line for conscription agreed yeah
totally everyone would then vote against
War every single time every time well
technically if our Representatives
listen to their constituents and the
president actually followed the rules
then we would have that mechanism yeah
well you could also here's the choices
if you support War if you vote in favor
of it you're conscripted Frontline
infantry if you vote against it you
voted against it congratulations you
don't got to fight or you can abstain
and what would happen is if you really
do want Thor but don't want to fight you
just don't vote and then maybe the
people who do fight and want war will
vote for it and then they will win the
vote so it's still possible for there to
be war in certain circumstances without
the majority of people voting for it but
I think overwhelmingly what would happen
is the NOS would be 80% yeah or the
Democrats would steal the
election the Democrats would just rig
We're Going To War World War II again
it's the ma and Republicans would be
like slow down there
Democrats and they would go the speed
limit and do the same thing Raymond g
Stanley J says shout out to my shout out
all my fellow handymen yeah it's funny
like the handy men are billionaires with
private jets because they're the only
ones who know how to fix things and no
one else does dude Raymond g Stanley
truly is Handy yeah and Randy Marsh is
like if if if you fix my stove I I'll
I'll teach you geology I have a PhD like
it's a completely worthless profession
in terms of like day-to-day living yeah
what did geologists do right now uh
maybe they make some money like
surveying I'm imagining well I know that
there there are some that they they they
do uh aerial uh they get aerial
photographs they look for for minerals
veins and things like that they know
where to find them and why but I mean
like in terms of actual geological
research what do they do a lot of
geologists that I know work in the
petroleum industry um that's where their
background is because of science I
couldn't say I was just say I wanted to
date a car guy because then I never had
to deal with my car again you know like
having someone in your life who is
practical and can actually fix things is
great true highly recommend BS it says
6066 60 of 66 credits 30k in debt no
degree because I failed college algebra
three times now running my own phone
repair business and could use that
30k yep I hear I just want to mention
something as a total aside because this
person's name was Bogart do you guys
know what a Boger is from Harry Potter
no what is it like a like a witch it's
not a witch like a troll in the in the
in the woods in the woods a bog yeah
those are the things that take the shape
of your worst fear and uh everyone's
right now saying like what is he talking
about no no no hold on like this I was
thinking about this recently this's a
classic reference what do you mean you
don't get it yeah like bardus it's a
Harry Potter man but uh but this is
important because in the movie in the
book it's like the teacher he looks at
it and turns into the moon cuz he's a
werewolf and he's scared of of that or
whatever and then I was just thinking
about it and I'm like like the concept
created by JK rling is really stupid
because it's impossible you know why do
you know what every person would see if
a manifestation of their worst fear
appeared before
them um a lot of people in a crowd
they're dead kids their dead wife their
dead husband their dead child the
greatest fear of the average person is
not bees or clowns it is staring at the
dead body of their loved one yeah true
and I'm like oh so that was a weird idea
but anyway I just like bog reminded me
of this thing I was thinking about and
I'm like but then actually apparently
that was in the book that like I guess
it was like uh Ron's mom yeah Ron's mom
saw her kids dead which was very sad
right and also when they do it in the
book you have to remember they're like
you know I don't even Middle School age
High School age children and so fears
are very different I think Ron's fear
was getting yelled at by essentially his
mom or something like that fear is an
interesting word cuz there's probably
different kinds of fear I was up really
high like 28 stories out on a balcony
and I was like whoa push couldn't like
that weird feeling of like getting that
fear of the heights is different than
the fear of losing a loved one like that
Terror but it's similar but it's it's
like it's hitting different areas of my
body I get what you mean yeah different
kinds of fear is there is there a list
of the seven different fears or
something like the different love that's
awesome that's F because there it's true
like the fear I feel when I see like a
wasp fing flying towards me is a totally
different feeling from the fear of like
when war is about to start like the
feeling that I got when they announce
the troop the the Personnel deployment
so be careful with troops and the the
two carrier groups going to the
Mediterranean it's like a sinking
feeling of dread but then like I see a
wasp it's like a shock where I'm just
like like an adrenaline rush but not I'm
not really scared it's more of like a
you know what I mean apply there are
three types of Fear main types Primal
irrational and rational no so the war
type would be rational it would be
rational fear to fear War whereas my
standing up high on a balcon is
irrational or maybe it's Primal no
that's not irrational irrational fears
like phobia it's like oh it's a clown oh
I'm terrified that's irrational and
Primal would be bees
something snakes something something
that induces fight or flight probably
yeah so there there are things like when
cats see cucumbers that's Primal Fear
like they're clearly not scared of the
Cucumber but think it could be a snake
because the cats evolved to be alert
when they see something that looks like
a snake and it's help them to survive
it's more Primal rational is like a bee
will sting me I will die and so I am I
am afraid of that irrational is ah it's
a clown run like that's a guy in a
costume why you why you scared of that
when I'm up high and I get that fear of
the of the falling off the edge I wonder
if that's Primal because like some
ancient ancestor fell from Great Heights
and it's in my DNA or something because
the humans who survived didn't fall and
so the humans who are more likely to be
afraid of heights were more likely to
survive so now within you it's ingrained
but uh in terms of the different types
of fear I'm saying like you get um jump
scares you turn a movie on and the and
then the ghost goes boo and you're like
like fear that's not Primal Fear stuff
jumping out of you at you no bro I'm
talking about you know there's like
Aeros and Phobos or whatever that's not
the same thing as you're describing
these are is not that's a Greek the
Greeks have the 10 kinds of love that's
what I'm talking about this is's
rational and irrational love as well
some people irrationally love inanimate
objects and they should not you know
what I mean that's totally different
from what I'm great topic this would be
well worth my biggest fear is a
geriatric president well you got it
living living in a constant nightmare
yeah you open the cabinet the Boger
comes out it's Joe Biden dude joking
that's the best part all right here we
go poly puree says I worked at a nuclear
power plant years ago water very tightly
contains the radiation they kept the
rods in a swimming pool yeah so there's
a a story of a scuba diver who got
sucked into like an intake valve and was
swimming in the reactor pool totally
fine because water blocks radiation yeah
probably in the spent fuel pool if he
was in the reactor pool it would be a
different story then there you go that
that might have been it also a I believe
it was in Japan um construction workers
or or um they so they were working
around the spent fuel pool and they had
a glass tube right and they stuck the
tube into the water and he looked into
it and it pretty much fried his brain I
now I don't know if that's like tribal
to the nuclear industry if it's like the
Boogeyman and we all talk about it but
I've heard that story he created a path
for the radiation yeah that's crazy and
that's why I always get bothered in
movies when they have like a remote
control underwater drone or something
cuz I've done this drone work I'm like
it's impossible you can't broadcast
signals through water it blocks
radiation so they if they have
underwater drones are wired and that's
why the drones they do have they're
wired and they do shallow surveys of
ships and stuff but going deeper you you
it has to be wired connection because
water blocks
radiation also I love how in space
liquid nitrogen is what they use to
insulate to keep something warm isn't
that crazy
yeah
you think you think it's the opposite
yeah you would but that's not how
vacuums work also you don't freeze in
outer space I I can't stand movies when
it's like they're in outer space
freezing that because there's no
moisture because there's no there's no
convection the heat can't escape your
body to anywhere so it stays where it is
and builds up and you get hotter and
hotter and then you you die yeah so like
in order for heat to leave your body you
need to blow it away and the transfer
the heat from one it has to convection
that's kind of like a nuclear meltdown
situation that's why the stuff melts
down cuz it can't get the heat out of it
yeah in outer space there's nowhere for
the heat to go you're in a vacuum so you
melt down yeah it's like in a thermos
the reason the way these things work is
they're vacuumed on you know on all
sides but one and so heat can only
Escape up whereas with a regular mug is
escaping in every
direction anyway the more you know the
wor the best part of having a political
show droing all the science we learn
along the way it's absolutely how they
contain spent nuclear fuel all right
Tyrion says as a Coloradan TDs is strong
here in the cities
what were you saying they they they they
they uh secure nuclear Fu they yeah they
they put nuclear yeah they draw they
draw vacuum on the container they
actually back fill it with helium and
then they yeah they draw the vacuum back
fill with helium and then the uh the the
the stainless steel shell can heat but
it's does the helium help like normalize
the pressure while and the temperature
right interesting you know helium's
finite and we're running out y we got to
fuse some hydrogen well once we figure
out Fusion we'll be able to mass produce
helium too so about that dyum oxide
right heavy hydrogen when you add a
neutron of the hydrogen smash it
together in a Palladium lattice I was
talking with Richie earlier he was like
fion is which one is fision and fusion
and we are talking about Fusion reactors
and fusion engines and uh it was
interesting conversation I'm going to
connect you guys to a buddy of mine that
actually has a startup company and uh he
he's he's right now going through the
licensing process and and through uh
Grant the Grant process with the doe
that he's probably the strongest
Advocate right now in the country to
recycle spent nuclear fuel genius guy I
think I think you'd love him all right
Keegan Mazo says welcome back Ian
there's a Russian Orthodox Monastery
being built in Wayne West Virginia I am
planning a pilgrimage to it soon I would
like to know if you wanted to go and see
it as well to get into contact with me
you can find me on the Discord Keegan
Mazo we should film it really yeah that
does sound cool we should do like a
little mini like 10-minute visit to the
Russian Orthodox Monastery and like you
know ask him what it's all about that'd
be great yes yeah fun
stuff we'll uh we'll grab some more
we'll grab some more where we at uh just
leave me alone says Florida Trump County
what does desus not understand about
that oh there you
go mine Brad says I work in nuclear
engineering you guys are doing a decent
job explaining risk is actually small
and there's a ton of backup protection
it would bring a lot of high paying
technical jobs it's clean energy
carbon carbon emission free we should be
building nuclear plants all over the
place so to be clear to the audience I
am not an engineer by trade I have a
master's degree in business I was
someone that was in management um you
know that I I managed and led a lot of
smart Engineers that were a heck of a
lot smarter than me so you know my my uh
my scientific knowledge or my technical
knowledge is all just based on
observation so you know some of the
questions you asked me I can't answer
them because I didn't have the technical
background so all
right not a fake it till you make it
again you did answer them but you were
honest that it's all me me learning and
and observing the people that that work
with me Isaac Gorski says why the hell
don't we just use the wheels of the cars
to create motion powered cars with their
own power source that's right I saw this
really funny video you may have seen it
where it's a car and they've got a a
generator strapped to the back right
wheel to so when the wheel spins it
spins the generator and it's charging
and they're like wow that's so smart and
these people are so dumb they don't
understand the conservation of energy
they don't understand the basic laws of
thermodynamics that all he's doing is
robbing his vehicle of energy by doing
that yeah but you know I will say shout
out to Mythbusters they created an an
internal what what was it it was an
internal kinetic motor and so the the
idea was that you could not create an
engine that was uh inside a boat to
cause motion because equal and opposite
reaction but it actually disproved it
and they were able to create forward
motion with an internal engine basically
the way it worked was it fires it it
sits in the middle of the boat doesn't
touch the water and it fires a piston
and then when the Piston hits the end it
pulls everything forward and the idea is
the pressure of moving the piston
forward creates an opposite reaction in
the other direction which should prevent
the boat from moving forward but I'm
pretty sure that it was myth buzzer who
did this they actually were able to
drive the boat forward using internal I
think it's because the Earth is round
and kind of always falling forward when
you're in the
water oh there goes the flat earthers
sorry and that is very wrong it might
have something to do with it but the way
the waves always kind of move towards
the shore like that has something to the
Moon also is pulling you the issue I
think it was actually really simple math
was that the the uh initial reaction
which fired the Piston does create uh a
reaction in both directions opposite
reaction right and then the catching of
the Piston creates a minor shock in One
Direction is what caused it and then
they've also got interesting uh uh I was
watching something about using uh was it
like firing electrons or photons inside
a device and then at a uh so this would
work outer space the amount of force
created from electrons hitting a plate
internally would would have no effect on
Earth because of friction and weight and
gravity but in outer space it would
build up enough to where over time it
would create speed yeah when uh when you
heat up one it's kind of how spores
travel through space the brighter side
of the spores on on top and then the
dark sides underneath so the brighter
side orients towards a star and then
begins to spin which creates gyration
and momentum I just love science it's so
funing well we got we got we got to go
regarding just do this really quick
regarding catching energy out of a
system like out of your car you can get
what's called extrae which is a little
bit of lost energy can be reused it
doesn't give you enough to propel the
system like a computer all that heat
coming out of your computer can be used
to like heat water and it can heat the
pipes in your house but all right we're
going to go to the members show so head
over to timcast.net join us the members
only show is starting in a couple
minutes you don't want to miss it we're
going to have callers talk to us and our
guest going to be great you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally at timcast smash that like
button share the show Jr do you want to
shout anything out no just uh you know
thanks for having me on and uh shout out
to all the people in northwest Ohio
we're going to beat Marcy capter this
cycle and um i' appreciate a follow on
Twitter or any other form of social
media Jr F Ohio is my website how far
from Pittsburgh um about three hours
three hours we're looking at doing an
event in p well to invite the Ohio out
yeah abolutely they love you in in the
ninth dude yeah they love us they love
us red white and blue Americans man I
went to Pittsburgh last weekend and I've
never been recognized more basically
like I I went to a poker room and the
lady was there she was like I knew it
was you and I was like oh thanks and
then like every table they're like oh
hey look at I'm like damn Pittsburgh
people know me I guess Midwest is the
best man I think but I think it's
because I have Chicago sensibilities and
so it's like midwesterners yeah are you
know we we kind of see these things and
we're not the coasts that it makes sense
but anyway well I'm all for the pro
Pittsburgh talking points even though
I've never been there uh I am really
glad that we were here tonight it was
fun to have fun conversation I'm Hannah
Clair brimo I'm a writer for timcast.net
and Instagram and follow timcast news
all the time always and if you want to
follow me personally I'm uh Hanah clare.
B on Instagram and HD bermo on Twitter
thank you guys so much and of course
welcome back to Ian once again thank you
an Clair I'm Ian cross and you guys
follow me hey anywhere everywhere hit me
up all over the Internet follow me
everywhere and I I'll talk to you there
JR people are hitting your website
what's the site uh jrf
ohio.com gorgeous good to see you man
thanks brother uh pleasure meeting you
Jr uh I am surge.com I'm excited for the
after show you guys should join up and
talk to us one day I'll be on the
Discord but not anytime soon catch you
later we will see you all over at
timcast.net
I